this is Jocko podcast number 187 with
David Burke and me Jacque a willing good
evening Dave good evening
in case anyone was wondering where Echo
Charles is at this time echo is actually
you know Hawaii trying to get back in
touch with Kaena the land as we used to
call it and he will be back in a few
more episodes in the meantime I got Dave
Burke here who now lives in the AO of
San Diego and if you don't know about
Dave he was on this podcast number 69
and number 135 he was a Marine Corps
fighter pilot through the f-18 he was a
Top Gun pilot Top Gun instructor Top Gun
senior instructor f-16 pilot f-22 pilot
f-35 pilot the first and still only one
of a few pilots qualified on all those
platforms he was the first commanding
officer of an f-35 operational squadron
and on top of that he was the commander
of anglich assault six on the ground
with us in the Battle of Ramadi and he
and his team did scores of operations
with tu bruiser
and he is now with us on the team at
Ashland front where he leads the
long-range leadership development and
alignment program today thanks for
coming on and filling in for echo it's
good to be here
have you been brushing up on your video
games and 80s and 90s movies
unfortunately no I'm not going to fill
in for that check well actually it's a
good thing that you do have the
experience that you have and it doesn't
have very much to do with Super Mario
Brothers because I want to talk tactics
and it's one of my rights I wrote that
it was one of my favorite Marine Corps
doctrinal publications that's that's
kind of a that's really a big statement
as if I sit around and grade which one's
my favorite
but it definitely is up there it is MC
dp1 TAC three tactics so let's get into
it how long how long were you in the
Marine Corps in four days 23 years 23
years and you retired as what a
lieutenant colonel lieutenant I'll check
did you sew you into the basic school I
did did you guys cover this in the basic
school absolutely actually when I went
to the basic school in 1994 it was the
predecessors basically the same pub the
1-3 and a different slightly different
name but pretty much the same stuff and
I actually looked this one is dated July
of 1997 I looked for a newer one then
there isn't one this is it
yeah and it's interesting because you'll
everyone will see there's examples in
here they don't have examples obviously
from Iraq and Afghanistan or Iraq - and
then Afghanistan I'm sure at some point
they will they will do that because they
got a lot of Gulf War examples and I you
know obviously they were just looking
for some recent examples when they did
it in 97 that was the last big war so
there you go but we'll get into it and
the book starts with a foreword and
because it's the Marine Corps the Marine
Corps even when they write a foreword it
sounds good
so this is how it starts off this
publication is about winning in combat
is there any better way to start this
manual nope this publication is about
winning in combat winning requires many
things excellence and techniques and
appreciation of the enemy exemplary
leadership battlefield judgment and
focused combat power yet these factors
by themselves do not ensure success in
battle many armors armies both winners
and losers have possessed many or all of
these attributes when we examine closely
the difference between the differences
between Victor and vanquished we draw
one conclusion success went to the
armies whose leaders
senior and junior could best focus their
efforts their skills and their resources
toward a decisive end
sounds like the Marine Corps is saying
that leadership is the most important
thing on the battlefield repeatedly and
when you're at TBS
you're there to be a leader that is what
you hear every single day leadership is
the difference
their success arose not merely from
excellence in techniques procedures and
materiel but from their leader but from
their leaders abilities to uniquely and
effectively combine them winning in
combat depends upon tactical leaders who
can think creatively and act decisively
so taking all of these techniques and
these procedures and and the material
and being able to take those things and
mix them up and combine them together
that is what makes that's the winning
combination the creativity how often did
people at TBS talk about being creative
believe it or not they never use those
didn't say be creative they would say
think they'd give it all this doctrine
in pubs and all these rules but they
would say you actually need to think and
think of what makes the most sense here
and they bred a lot of flexibility I
never remember anybody saying be
creative but they said think about it
think of this makes sense and if it
doesn't do something else and these are
the rules the guidelines but there was
always as maneuvering around there to
bring all those pieces together I say
that combat is an exercise in creativity
and people especially people that don't
know anything about combat or war
anything they always kind of that always
surprises them right because they think
creative being creative is writing a
song or painting a picture but for me
being a creative is positioning your
machine-gunners effectively yeah right I
mean that's that's like true creativity
yeah it's leader it's not a template it
isn't just here's what to do in this
situation you have to think you have to
think creatively and come up with the
best idea I see that in mixed martial
arts or one of one of my favorite mixed
martial artists of all time do you know
who phaidor Emelianenko is I do
you do I do okay I'm impressed with your
knowledge so two things about Fodor
number one he was completely stoic and
never showed any emotions
win or lose didn't matter you could look
at him after a fight and you wouldn't
know if he just won the pride GP or if
he just lost his first match in his life
he looked the same and so that's one
very good lesson learned from phaidor
the other lesson learned from fedoras
phaidor would take the skills that he
had and applied them in very creative
ways where you'd say oh he just did you
know a judo throw followed by a
submission assam bow submission attempt
followed by just dropping bombs of
ground-and-pound and and those are all
three separate things and he would just
mix them up all really well together and
that when you see that's like the new
level of mixed martial arts is the older
generation hey I was really good at Jiu
Jitsu or hey I was really good at
wrestling or hey I was really good at
striking and I would kind of stay in my
lane and if I could bring you into my
world I could beat you now it's just who
has who can take all these tools and get
creative with them and apply them to
this scenario that they're in
same thing with leadership same thing
with combat leadership and by the way
same thing with all leadership sand
doesn't only apply to combat check
alright moving on this book pertains
equally to all Marine leaders whether
their duties entail combat service
support combat support or combat arms
all Marines face tactical decisions in
battle regardless of their roles
tactical leaders must develop and hone
their war fighting skills through study
and practice this publication serves as
a guide for that professional
development it addresses the theory of
tactics and its application in a chaotic
and uncertain environment the concepts
and ideas within this publication are
battle tested throughout our history one
of the most important reasons for the
success of the United States Marine
Corps has been the military skill of our
leaders at every level level of command
through their tactical skill and
battlefield judgment our commanders
achieve tactical and operational
advantage at the decisive time and place
and they talk a lot about the chaotic
and uncertain environment which as we
know that's what combat is and by the
way that's what life is
that's what business is that's what the
world is so getting into Chapter one
understanding tactics such a straight
forward the Marine Corps the Marine
Corps doctrines doctrinal materialists
so straightforward and so simply written
it's just outstanding starts off with a
couple quotes in tactics the most
important thing is not whether you go
left or right but why you go left or
right and that's from general al gray
29th Commandant of the Marine Corps
forty-one years three purple hearts
Korea Vietnam a Mustang officer by the
way get some he's the only one he's the
only is the only Commandant that's
pictured in his in his official picture
as the comment on the Marine Corps in
his camp in this game is absolutely get
some he's a legend I I think I had liked
it maybe a year or two overlapped with
him where I was in and he was in I think
he retired in like 91 and 92 or
something like that and yeah so there
you go the most important thing is why
understanding why this is underlying
tenant really of decentralized command
but of all leadership next one is next
quotas there is only one principle of
war and that's this hit the other fellow
as quick as you can as hard as you can
where it hurts him the most when he
ain't looking that's Sir William slim
who's actually a Brit fought World War
one and World War two what's up with
fighting in World War one and the world
war ii totally matter
it's just it like we've talked about
World War one on this podcast a few
times you and I have and did what a
savage experienced and in a role right
back and do it again here you know 25
years later yeah yeah what's up with
that hey yeah you know you barely
survived
guess what go get some more and by the
way he like led the fight in Japan led
the fight against Japan and in Burma I
mean that guy was no joke so there's the
principal go hard go fast hit him when
they're not looking alright continuing
on this book is about winning in combat
when he requires a thorough
understanding of and knowledge of
tactics but what is tactics an art and a
science tactics is the art and science
of winning engagements and battles it
includes the use of firepower and
maneuver the integration of different
arms and the immediate exploitation of
success to defeat the enemy as well as
the sustainment
of forces during combat so think about
that right there you got you got the art
and science it includes firepower
firepower maneuver cover move fire
maneuver right different arms taking all
the different all the different assets
that you have and applying them
correctly and then on top of that the
immediate exploitation of success to
defeat the enemy so when things are
going good and you see the enemy start
to crack it's time to go drop the hammer
yep it also includes the technical
application of combat power which
consists of those techniques and
procedures for accomplishing specific
tax within a tactical action so I guess
they're saying technical application of
combat power this is like one level
below tactics this is like you're gonna
shoot correctly you're gonna yeah and
you actually have to know how all of
your equipment works this machine gun
will go this far be effective at this
range and beyond that range you need
another piece of equipment so you have
to actually know all these technical
things it's no different than an
airplane you have to have all the
understanding of how all these things
work but that by itself isn't enough
that's where the creativity comes in and
hey I'm gonna use this machine gun to
get this reaction and they're gonna move
in some other direction and then I'm
gonna apply
other combat power have to know what
that power can do and where and how it
works and that's the art that they're
talking about is bringing all these
things in together and the good
commanders recognize they see a go now
it's time for this not because the book
says the range because they see it as a
leader and to apply that I was in they
talk for the first the 506 in Ramadi and
their battalion commander was just like
such a legit guy and there was a lot of
mayhem going on and he's sitting there
in a chair in the talk just you know
just a normal whatever crappy chair and
any they're getting questions from the
field they want to drop like a building
they wanted to call QF there was a bunch
of things going on and he'd this guy he
was just and I wonder he's gonna be on
the podcast he was just but I'm just
watching him and this is when I first
got to her money I'm watching this guy
and they're going hey sir they want to
bring tanks down to this area they got
through there to receive and fire and
he'd let look at it kind of glance over
the map and he'd be it's a do it just as
calm as you could possibly be pretty
awesome yeah that guy had some some
serious he had the he had a good handle
on the art in the science back to the
bulk tactics refers to the concepts and
methods we use to accomplish a
particular military in a particular
objective in either combat or military
operations other than war in war tactics
is the application of combat power to
defeat the enemy and engagements and
battles combat power is the total
destructive force we can bring to bear
against the enemy it is a unique product
of the river of a variety of physical
moral and mental factors see so this so
this is when you start talking about
leadership right because because
okay the physical thing we get we get
what guns are we get what airplanes are
we get what tactical maneuvers are but
then when you start talking about the
the moral and the mental factors and how
you're gonna get a bunch of human beings
to do something that is gonna be
dangerous to them yeah and to expect
that from a nineteen year old Marine he
they said at the beginning this is
leadership at every level lance
corporals fire two
leaders and expecting and demanding that
they behave morally in what's going to
be maybe the most brutal physical
situation they'll be in their lives and
recognizing that without that you're
gonna lose in the long run that's a
losing plan to be devoid of morals in
doing this in combat it's pretty amazing
that's the the super strategic picture
yeah the long game they realize without
it in the end we will lose if we don't
have if we don't have the moral high
ground whose ratings
tactics results in the actions and
counter actions between opposing forces
it includes the use of maneuver
supported by the application and
coordination of fires to gain advantage
in order to defeat the enemy in military
operations other than war tactics may be
the schemes and methods by which we
perform other missions such as to
control a crowd or provide a secure
environment for the delivery of food
medicine or supplies to a nation or
people in need as stated in the
definition I wonder if this will get one
when this gets rewritten right now if
they'll tone back if they won't mention
as much like the military operations
other than war
because that in 1997 there was a lot of
it kind of seemed like what the world
was gonna be now you know it's gonna be
hey look we might not be fighting a war
ever again but we at lino we're gonna be
doing things that will require that's
what they called it military first for
those of you that are wondering what
that is military operations other than
war this is like a humanitarian
assistance mission this is like a
security and stabilization mission so
those kind of things
crowd control those kind of things are
what they're talking about and in the
this was written in 97 so and it's
certainly you certainly could have if
you had a naive view of the world you
certainly could have fought yourself you
know are we really gonna fight another
like actual war are we really gonna do
that and it's really easy to look at it
from a logical perspective and say
listen America is just this giant
country we have this super military
force and technology and
no one is gonna step up to the plate yes
Ryan get some right so let's just focus
on these other things be pretty easy to
think that yeah I actually remember when
I was going on the Marine Corps in 94
Desert Storm was in the rear view mirror
I kind of missed that big op and I
remember thinking I wonder if I'm ever
really gonna get into combat you know
and a lot of years went by before the
opportunity was there and a lot of us
thought that might never happen in my
career yeah a lot of people never did
they spent that decade in between 91
2001 that did eight nine 10 years and
that got out and never saw anything like
that I know guys that did 25 30 years
came in in 1973 1974 1975
you know 1971 like if you joined if you
got to the SEAL Teams in 1971 or 1972
you didn't you you know you didn't go to
Vietnam
yeah well actually so let's look at it
you if you went straight into the seal
the SEAL Teams you you joined in 1970 it
took you it took you you know to go
through boot camp the next thing you
know it's 1971 and a half and then you
show up at a SEAL team and now it's 1972
and there's no they're not pulling all
tunes anymore yeah so there's a couple
there's some some odds and ends are
still going over but they're not
deploying straight up platoon so if
you're a new guy you don't go and now if
you didn't do anything in the Gulf which
was there's a couple platoons in the
Gulf there's a couple attunes and Panama
there's a couple platoons and Grenada
though you don't I mean it's like if you
weren't one of those people you could
easily have gone through 30-year career
next thing you know you look up its 2001
you're you well to the year 2000 and
you're retiring to 1970 to 2000 yeah
people sometimes forget the Gulf War was
like four days you know the sustained
combat operations was like 96 hours
something like that and if you miss that
which a lot of people did that was the
big show in an entire generation yeah
going back to the book as the as stated
in the definition tactics is a
combination of art and science to gain
victory over the enemy
the art of tactics lies in how we create
creative creatively form and apply
military force in a given situation I
really like talking about that
creatively form and apply military force
in a given situation it involves the
creation positioning and maneuver of
combat power when do we flank the enemy
and when do we ambush him when do we
attack and when do we infiltrate how do
we use speed and momentum to achieve a
decisive advantage this creativity is
developed as a developed capacity
acquired through education practice and
experience how much more how much more
qualified are you right now to be on the
battleground they'd be on the
battlefield in Ramadi in 2006 how much
more qualified are you now than you were
then the things that I would see now the
things that I would know to look for now
that I didn't even think of then and
what you just said that that that last
comment that that's everywhere that that
that training P all the pieces that go
into that and and any one of them
without the other doesn't work you can't
just be awesome at one thing you can't
just be all about the signs of these
things and and when you usually work
creativity I mean when you see people do
things like that and it's like it's like
artistry you see just the flow when the
maneuvers and the things that are coming
in and I'm sure that that first the five
or six when he said do it he's actually
looking up and seeing this is the
reaction that I'm gonna get this is
what's gonna happen whether that happens
you know he's seeing those things and I
love that image of him just sitting
there in the chair and like you know do
it ya know and knowing what's gonna
happen you know well boom yet beyond
what what people can see it in real time
and knowing that you can't know what's
gonna happen for sure at the same time
your Center yeah do it and then you're
thinking okay I know there's a bad
least at eighty percent chance that this
goes the way I'm thinking ago and
there's also a 20 percent chance that
this isn't something completely
different happens man he's also totally
relinquished control of of what happens
next I mean there's nothing he can do
once he says do it he's totally
relinquished control of what's gonna
happen at that point with this guy's and
you know that's it and the best leaders
they're completely comfortable doing
that because they know what their guys
are gonna do because they have trained
them so hard they have repeated that
situation so many times that they're for
all the chaos that is definitely going
to ensue he's extremely he knows exactly
what his guys are gonna do and how
they're gonna react back to the book the
science of tactics lies in the tactical
application the technical application of
combat power it includes mastering the
techniques and procedures that
contribute to the development of
warfighting such as mark marksmanship
navigation gunnery and close air support
the execution of these techniques and
procedures must become second nature for
us this requires intensive and
continuous training without mastery of
basic war fighting skills artistry and
creativity in their application are
impossible discipline equals freedom
you've got to have the discipline on the
little things and then you can get
creative with them
now that we've examined the art and
science of tactics let us look at how we
can use tactics to complement strategy
and campaigning strategy and campaign
bring our forces to a particular place
in a particular time we use tactics to
win in combat a war typically involves
many individual engagements that form a
continuous fabric of activity war
typically involves many individual
engagements that form a continuous
fabric of activity there's so much going
on in war you know when we did our first
big push into I guess it was cop iron
and there was 50 armor pieces that were
getting ready to go and like one of them
looks someone from the 137 was just
talking about okay well you here's where
we're at with fuel and of course you
know we had fuel for our home views
Humvees or whatever you know like we
drive around but they had 50 armor
pieces that drink diesel like what do
you think they get - I mean it's just
something it's just something completely
crazy probably two miles to the gallon
or something like that
yeah I think it's gallons per mile yeah
I think it's it's that much more see
that much yeah but but here we were just
thinking okay well the armor just gonna
be where the armors got to be and that's
all good but they're thinking oh
actually you know we need to have
whatever thousands and thousands of
gallons of diesel fuels got to be here
it's got to be there it's got to be
delivered it's got to be good and it's
coming from where it's coming from some
totally different place and all that
stuff has to be orchestrated and boom
and there you go now we're going on this
combat operation there's so much going
on and by the way convoys get hit fuel
big fuel trucks that have 28,000 gallons
they get hit on an ambush yes and they
don't even make it to Ramadi like that
happened regularly yep absolutely and on
the other side of that money that phrase
that continuous fabric you also have to
get the folks at your lowest level the
folks out there with a rifle maybe the
guys driving the tank
recognize how everything every
individual thing they do actually
affects this whole campaign and that
even those small individual actions that
seem like there's nothing else going on
in the world other than you and maybe
that that's sniper on the roof or that
position that even your interaction with
that one thing will have implications
all the way down to the entire campaign
into the strategic level the Marine
Corps I don't think they say it anymore
they used to have a phrase called the
strategic corporal with the recognition
that even this engagement you were
influencing so many other things at this
broad level that you actually have to be
aware of your actions and that gets back
to that comment about even the moral
behavior think of the times that we saw
guys do things that we knew were wrong
and how it totally undermined the big
strategy because everything got shifted
away from the war and got shifted
towards whether we did something right
or wrong and got on the news and all
this yeah that Abu Ghraib is the one I
always talk about I regret for sure look
but a couple some people acting like
knuckleheads yep and next thing you know
that that that event completely fueled
the insurgency for sure that ninety
tactical that people a tiny tactical
event had massive think of how many
enemy fighters that recruited and made
our job strategically that much harder
back to the book in combat our objective
is victory check sometimes this involves
the complete destruction of enemy of the
enemy's forces at other times achieving
victory may be possible by attacking the
enemy's will to fight the Marine Corps
must be equally prepared to win during
both situations those in which the enemy
forces must be completely destroyed as
during world war two and those in which
the complete destruction of the enemy's
forces it may not be necessary or even
desirable as the commanding general of
the 1st Marine Division in Desert Storm
stated our focus was not on destroying
everything our focus was on the Iraqi
mind and getting behind it he knew that
the path to victory did not lie in the
total destruction of Iraqi forces but in
undermining their will to fight which
they certainly did very effectively yeah
the environment next section the
tactical arena is a dynamic
ever-changing environment the complexity
of this environment makes combat chaotic
and unpredictable as an example of
confusion and chaos on the battlefield
consider the amphibious assault on the
island of Tarawa in November 1943 during
the assault the combination of high
casualties lack of effective
communications and disruption of the
second and eighth marine regiments
landings on the assault beaches led to a
chaotic and nearly disastrous situation
for the second Marine Division units
were decimated under heavy fire
surviving Marines huddled together under
a coconut log seawall in in Inner
Mongolia Mnet's without effective
communications landing craft carrying
reinforcements and supplies could not
make it over a coral reef to the landing
beaches only through daring leadership
initiative and teamwork we're Marines
able to get off the beach and annihilate
the defending Japanese force the
violence of combat only increases the
level of confusion and chaos Robert
Sherrod a time and Life correspondent at
Iwo Jima gave testimony to this chaos
and what he called war at its worst the
first night on Iwo Jima can only be
described as a nightmare in hell about
the beach in the morning lay the dead
they had died with the greatest possible
violence nowhere in the Pacific have I
seen such badly mangled bodies many were
cut squarely in half legs and arms lay
fifty feet from any body battle is the
collision of opposing forces animate
interactive and unpredictable
unpredictable in behavior performance
varies from week to week day to day and
even hour to hour as a unit interacts
with its environment
and the enemy ruff I know you and I
often joke about our complete and utter
our experience just pales I mean
obviously in comparison to the guys that
fought at Tarawa the guys that fought at
Iwo Jima the guys that fought in Europe
in World War two and you get in those
environments right those environments
and it is this this idea of this dynamic
and complex and ever-changing
battlefield there it is yeah I've said
it a few times and I still feel this way
I'm embarrassed sometimes to call what I
did in an airplane combat it I read
these books and I listened to the
podcast and listen to these stories and
it's almost hard for me to even try to
relate to the idea of that I was in
combat in an airplane you know given
what these things sound like what do you
think about those King bee pilots from
from till yeah I'd love to share swap
stories of those guys you know that what
what did I do compared to what would
they do you know there's a quote that I
didn't read and I don't know why didn't
I had it marked but I just didn't read
it but there was like a situation on the
ground there was total enemy fire
everywhere and like one aircraft
approach that got shot out and the team
on the ground this is this was one it
was either one of two it's one of one of
the SOG crews who was down on the ground
and they're just trying to get extracted
and the basically all the pilots are
like hey we can't go in you guys need to
move to a different extract you need to
go somewhere else like we need more fire
support we can't get in there and this
one pilot this one King bee pilot comes
on and he just comes on the mic and says
King bee goes down meaning hey I'm going
in yeah whatever
there's enemy fire cool watch this
so legit I love how this book is called
tactics this book about tactics and I
think that section we're on is called
understanding tactics and they're
talking about the chaos of war and it's
not a book just about tactics do this do
that this is what work it's it's about
war and you said it a couple times
success in combat is the only
measurement the Marine Corps has ever
given their Marines to be successful in
combat and to remind them of just how
hard that actually is and the things
that you're going to see and smell and
feel and endure in combat is well beyond
what we can replicate in training and
this serves as a reminder you know day
one of you would Jima and it gets back
to we said it would be pretty arrogant
to think that a day like that could
never happen again in the future that
we're never gonna have something like
that ever again I had a guy working for
a guy and doing a project where we the
the brief that was given was listen we
need as seals to kind of like move in a
different direction because since we
have you know satellite coverage we
don't need to do reconnaissance anymore
and since we have T lambs we don't need
to do direct action cuz we could just
send a GPS guided missile like why would
you send troops on the ground to go do
that like there's no reason to and and
this was you know this was around the
same time period this was like 96 97 and
the theory was look we will not what we
as seals are not gonna do a direct
action mission again it's just not gonna
happen
and you know I mean I was sitting there
listening I was disappointed to hear
that but it was hard for me to think
what could bring that about right
because every scenario I could think of
was oh well you just you just send in a
teal amp right that's what you do okay
maybe I was thinking maybe like a
hostage rescue scenario okay that's the
one ma'am how often is that happening
right so like yeah and then you know you
fast-forward what was it five or six
years from there and I was doing it I
was doing a direct actually raid almost
every night of the week in Baghdad
and we happen for 15 years yes yes
exactly when I got to the fleet in 1998
my first fighter squadron combat capable
squadron we got introduced to GPS
weapons first squadron in the Marine
Corps to get a gps weapon and the brief
that I was given was you'll never over
fly the target again you now have a
weapon that you can release from a
standoff range that will guide itself to
the target you'll never have to overfly
the target which meant the the risk goes
down you'll never have to be worth as
smaller never over fly the target again
and and and it was three years later you
know we kick things off and think of how
many times we had an aircraft directly
overhead in every one of those missions
you know exposed to the enemy and that
complacency that came in from technology
will solve these problems for us what
was the threat to your aircraft when
your support and troops on the ground
and Afghanistan
the threat was small arms and and
shoulder-fired ir MANPADS it called it
you know sa sevens these short-range
missiles which the thing of it is is
that if you get outside the 3/4 mile
range there are no they're literally no
threat at all but if you get inside that
range almost anybody in the world could
pick one of those things up look through
a little optic and shoot it and the
missile goes after the heat signature
and they were they were everywhere I
went to Stinger missile school yeah and
yes it's not it's not a hard weapon to
know to work I mean it's it this school
is like a week-long I mean it's not a
long school and you go to that school
and then you can pick up one of those
things and like you just said I mean if
if I pulled out the manual right now I
could progress you down an aircraft
pretty easily have you had spent the
last 10 years fighting against the
Russians and yet you could definitely
shoot out an American airplane and
that's what we're dealing with this guys
that had actually a lot of experience
with it and that stuff was everywhere
yeah
never over find the target - you were
directly over over at the target at very
low altitudes because you needed to be a
little altitude to provide the support
at huge risk look and there's certainly
a balance technology has allowed us to
do a whole bunch of things and that's
that's good stuff but hey we'll never
have this happen to us again meaning our
human beings are never gonna be put in
those situations again it's and I love
how this manual is that's what it's
telling the Marines hey read this book
oh by the way this is what
happen and it's going we know it's going
to happening and I don't know when or
where it's going to happen again for
sure and you know you were pointing out
that and this is this is actually I'm
gonna point this out later I think I'm
gonna point this out later as a
shortfall to this book but what you're
pointing out right now is is you know
it's not about to do this or do that
because think about it what have they
told you what have they taught what tax
is if they talked about so far zero
they've talked about zero tactics what
they've told you is get ready for mayhem
yeah learn the fundamental tactics and
then get ready for total mayhem that's
what they've told you so far be creative
that's what they've said they've used
the word creativity like over and over
again yeah that's what they're trying to
get into your heads they haven't even
told you any tactics yet so and I think
part of that reason is because there is
a fundamental baseline that all Marines
have yeah that they assume and so they
don't really talk about it in here and
maybe that's the reason why I pictured
us a little bit of a shortfall of hey
this is tactic which is like if you've
read the book the last hundred yards
which gets very in the weeds on tactics
like the actual maneuvering small
elements and this doesn't really have it
and I think the reason it doesn't really
have it is because of the assumed
knowledge of every marine yeah for sure
and I think to put some context around
this the Marine Corps knows and expects
the the actual tactics are gonna be
taught at school is school there yeah
and they're what the Marine Corps think
is really trying to get the youngest
junior Marines whether it's a junior
marine leader an officer a lieutenant or
a young private is what tactics means
not the application of the tactic itself
but what does it mean to be part of the
tactic for winning and it's everything
from understanding the nomenclature of
your weapon to the brutal nature of war
and they know that what's required is
actually going to learn the tactics that
you will apply as an artillery man or an
infantryman or a supply officer or a
logisticians
but tactics make no mistake that is the
brutal application of war you know what
this reminds me of so when we're working
with when we are working with a company
at echelon front it seems like
oftentimes what people learn about
business like let's say they get their
MBA from somewhere or they or even if
they've gone through some kind of a
program whatever kind of program what
they learn is actually the maneuvering
of the battlefield like they learn how
to they learned that technical part of
it yeah and the part that they don't
often know is all this gear oh this is
gonna be complete and total mayhem yeah
like things that you had no idea what oh
by the way Oh leadership what you need
to do is surround yourself with some
good people okay and by the way half
those good people are gonna be crazy the
other half are gonna be insane yeah
right like every every like that's
what's missing so what they focus on
here is kind of what we focus on at
Ashkelon front working with companies oh
like there's gonna be things that aren't
going the way youth the way they were
gonna be going on paper when you made
that hire or when you open that branch
or whatever you did it's interesting you
know it's I think it's exactly the same
for sure check going back to the book
military forces are complex systems
consisting of individuals and equipment
they interact internally and externally
in seemingly chaotic ways as Clausewitz
wrote a battalion is made up of
individuals the least important of whom
may chance to delay things or make them
go wrong that's what I was just saying
like that that sentence is so the least
important person yes can literally
destroy your plane yes yeah as Marines
we believe in the we believe the actions
of single individuals can have great
impact in combat can also make things go
right
for example Sergeant John Basilone as a
machine gunner at Guadalcanal
contributed and this is a quote in large
measure to the virtual annihilation of a
Japanese regiment he steadfastly manned
his position in the face of repeated
wave type assaults and was instrumental
in breaking the enemy's ability to press
the attack forcing them to retreat
without achieving their goals Medal of
Honor for that situation Navy Cross
later where when he was killed at Iwo
Jima but virtual annihilation of a
Japanese regiment
Bazzi
yeah a legend battle is also influenced
by a variety of external conditions
directions and missions established by
authorities terrain weather attitudes of
the civilian populace that often cannot
be foreseen the outcome of combat can
only be anticipated in terms of
probabilities all those things
authorities terrain weather attitudes of
this really terrain you're looking at it
you're looking at a map a 1 to 50000 map
or even a 1 to 24 map which is twice as
good sometimes that terrain doesn't even
reflect anything that you've that you
thought it was gonna look like yeah the
people that that part the people I mean
that's the piece to the think about that
I'd like you to consider the attitudes
of the people in the application of this
plan and the amount of chaos that's
embedded just in that comment it's it's
it's staggering and then again we're
linked wish control to your people and
have them go deal with that as it
happens in real time yeah we're gonna
send you into a city that's that's been
under a regime that's now got insurgents
in there there's people getting killed
they're trying to survive there from a
totally different culture consider that
and just get a plan around that would
you just add that as one of the factors
and the weather or - yeah I think yeah
and that happens in the business world -
totally you get things completely wrong
get things completely wrong all this so
far I'm sure everyone's gonna love this
new product we're making no no one likes
it doesn't sell anything or I was
working with a company and they made
something and they anticipated selling
between 2 & 4 per shop that they were
going into a massive spread of shops a
very large chain of shops and they made
this something they were anticipating
selling between 2 & 4 per shop and they
ended up selling on average 34 per shop
per day like crazy
yeah who predicted that no one then
they're spending 20 million dollars on a
new factory immediately check back to
the book technology also affects the
tactical environment but not always as
anticipated technology may reduce
uncertainty and it may also increase it
the Spartans organized in the Phalanx is
attacked and close formation making it
easy to see and control ones forces
today tactical formations are less well
defined as distances between elements
have increased complicating command and
control in increased weapons lethality
communications range and tactical
mobility cause us to disperse forces
over greater distances war is more fluid
as a result of technology while the
machine gun bogged down warfare in World
War one tactical innovations like the
tank the airplane and the aircraft
carrier made warfare more rapid and
free-flowing in World War 2 so that's
that's what you just talked about with
technology the the GPS guided bomb yeah
and as a pilot I was pretty much on the
leading edge of tactical evolution in in
in aviation and it was it was awesome
there was more did you guys start flying
night-vision goggles so I have a very
similar story to you I had my first
night-vision goggle flight in the summer
of 1998 and they were pretty new at the
time and I so get this I go on my we do
like a simulator we do a brief I learn
how it works and up in like a darkroom
and everything but you can't replicate
it till you get in an airplane and the
first airplane you have an instructor in
the back we get in the airplane go do
the whole thing we get airborne we're
out here Southern California I've talked
took off out of
before clothes just over the water and
I'm looking up and I'm looking at all
the airplanes at LAX lined up hundreds
of miles away I can see this with my
night-vision goggles and I asked the
instructor hey is this is pretty common
ease like well I can't actually see what
you're looking at I said how come he
says I'm not wearing my goggles and this
was kind of a really old really kind of
senior crusty guy I think was it
originally an eight-six pile of the
transition he goes I don't like him and
I remember I was a really young student
that time so I certainly wasn't gonna
have I'm sure that and go to that it
didn't really occur to me till years
later talking you know conversation we
had about when the seals are trying to
introduce goggles and guys like hey we
don't need that kind of stuff
yeah and just thinking how being in it
like that is the most insane thing I've
ever heard but but but just something to
think about I have been on flights it
happened actually twice once in a combat
mission in Afghanistan where my wingman
took off and he didn't have his bracket
he forgot his bracket that attaches the
helmet where you put the goggles on so
he reached down to get the night vision
goggles to mount him on his helmet
airborne he's like dude I don't have my
bracket weight which means no goggles
period so we're gonna go do seven hours
without without him having night-vision
goggles and he was kind of paralyzed by
that oh yeah yeah so he had put himself
in this technology and then the moment
that technological thing he'd been just
accustomed who's gone he he didn't know
what to do was like hey hang man we're
puttin a couple of risk mitigated oh
just a mile to Delta and we'll a couple
of very easy things we could do but it
was hard for him and that the technology
in and of itself doesn't solve your
problems unless you can a know how to
use it and react when it's not giving
you what you want and I've seen that in
airplanes all the time that all of a
sudden
GPS goes down in an airplane and what
you want to do is they let's just go
home like we can't go home we're here to
support it and I've seen guys get
paralyzed by losing that technological
thing that they become accustomed to and
that's kind of the beauty of others are
saying here's hey there's a basic thing
that's going to go on here that you have
to be able to execute they can't
replicate the invasion of Tarla being
pinned down and watching a regiment get
decimated you can't replicate that in
combat
and you can't replicate telling a guy
get up in a hail of gunfire and lead
your men but you can actually you can
actually get people to recognize that
that's what you need to do in those
situations and that's why those mornings
actually got up and did that this is the
contrast incredible the dichotomy of
that is incredible to think about yeah
the the technology thing the GPS you
know like there wasn't GPS when I first
got in there was but it wasn't a
feasible thing to use because it was
slow and it just didn't work and and I
remember getting told hey we know with
this piece of equipment we we can know
exactly where we are and it weighed 28
pounds so I said hey I know exactly what
I am and I have a map and compass yeah
so next question let's move on and and
and there's definitely are guys that
have become reliant on GPS they do not
know how to do land nav and land nav is
an absolutely critical skill if you know
land map you don't need to look at your
GPS in fact if you know it well you
don't even need to look at your map
right you remember the terrain features
you're keeping track your pace and you
know exactly where you are I didn't use
a GPS or a map in ramadi after the
second week inside the city except on
very rare occasions but every Spears
giulio I knew where I was because well
we did it all the time but that was
actually if I had to say hang on one
second let me orient myself to this it's
over like let me break out my GPS and
see where we are so those fundamental
skills are actually required to be able
to take advantage of the technology when
I looked back at my first deployment to
Iraq
once we were in Ramadi for like a month
I really cuz my first deployment we'd be
going all over the place you know we did
a lot of working back that but back that
is huge and we wouldn't do the same
neighborhood even you know maybe we do
the same neighborhood one or two times
but most as I must say we just never
been here before and I realized how much
better I should have known the the
terrain like I would be looking at the
battle map going into a on my first
deployment we'd be going into some
random town ok here's a major landmark
there's a mosque over here there's a
there's a bridge over here cool I got
that oh yeah this building looks pretty
particular our target building is right
next to that building so ok so I'd kind
of have
level of familiarize Asian but I
wouldn't know it like what we knew when
in Ramadi where you're looking at the
same thing all the time and that's how
you should know the terrain that's how I
should study the trade and then when
something doesn't fit in the way it is
the way you the way it's supposed to
then you will recognize like if you're
looking at a rural environment because
rural environments I think are tougher
to read I guess clearly they aren't
tougher to read than city environments
although you can get turned around in
the city as well but you know a stream
or a you know you you hit a little
stream that wasn't on the map and you
think you're at the big one and bah bah
bah bah
you can just get Richard up but if you
are tracking it then you can you can
make sense of it if you studied it more
so be careful of completely relying on
technology it can is not always your
friend back to the book future battles
likely to become even more chaotic
although combat in Operation Desert
Storm was between fairly well-defined
forces in a well-defined space the
forces and operating areas in Vietnam
Somalia and Grenada were far less well
defined enemy units were dispersed and
often hidden with within the civilian
population making them hard hard to
detect and harder to target they
converge at a time and place of their
choosing future opponents may choose to
fight in this manner to offset our
overwhelming superiority and firepower
little foreshadowing is it then yes they
may choose to fight that way continuing
on this chaotic environment also brings
opportunity Klaus Fritz wrote about
combat no other human activity is so
continuously bound up with chance the
challenge is to recognize opportunity
when it occurs in the midst of chaos and
uncertainty and to seize it to obtain a
clear unambiguous victory when viewed
through time even the most chaotic of
systems may reveal recurring patterns
that may look that may then be exploited
the experienced tactician will look for
these reoccurring patterns that
can be exploited to advantage I mean
where is that not true
that statement and and then that's
combat in a nutshell but I mean I talked
about the OODA loop all the time in
aviation and and in in business too and
you see the people when you're working
with folks and it's their first time
maybe they've gotten a their first team
and you know they introduce themselves
in a first couple weeks and and very
immediately things don't go the way that
they want and they're on their heels and
they don't know how to react and it's
not because they're bad leader it's not
because they don't possess its they'd
never seen it before and if you've never
seen it before
a lot of times you don't know what to do
so you you freeze or you do or you do
nothing or you make the wrong decision
but it's really that sense of being
overwhelmed and right next to might be
someone they've been doing it for ten
fifteen years and okay hey man I've seen
this a thousand times and they reacted
completely differently I've never seen a
place where that isn't true I mean that
experience of doing things over and over
again to find a pattern go this is how I
think this is gonna work out that's what
lets you go do it because you can
anticipate what that outcome is gonna be
cuz you've seen it so many times yeah
and there's there's a way of looking at
things and overlaying your knowledge
that allows you to see things that other
people don't see and it's hard to do and
not many people do it not many people
take what they're the knowledge that
they have and overlay it onto what
they're looking at and you can't what
you can't do is you can't let what
you're overlaying block what's behind it
you have to overlay it it has to be
transparent because you have to be able
to see through it you have to be able to
see the changes but if you can take your
experience and you can overlay it on to
what's Happ on to what's happening it
gives you this massive advantage it's a
huge advantage we talked about when
flying having a mental rolodex of
literally a billion different but almost
like screen captures of what you're
seeing out your wins
in your world that you're looking at as
a pilot and having however much
experience you have back that on your
head to go I've seen that before I can
pull from my memory or my recollection
of things I've thought about kind of
overlay that just like you said and look
through it almost transparently and go
these are the same and it doesn't
guarantee that you know exactly what's
gonna happen next but it narrows down to
such a small margin of what the likely
outcomes are gonna be that you're that's
how you start thinking ahead of your
opponent or the person even next to you
is being able to pull that experience
and say that I've seen this and I think
this is what's gonna happen cuz of all
these other things but just like you
said - you don't get to freeze time you
don't there's no pause button there
airplanes are moving hundreds of miles
an hour dynamically and and the guys
that do that really well pull those
pictures out and go I've seen this and
they're making moves in you look how how
did you know to do that and it's exactly
what you just described I was at the
training command I was running training
and we got tasked with training the guys
in a new mission and so we get we tasked
the guys with this new mission and they
come up with a plan to execute this new
mission and so when whenever we were
taking the guys on a field training
exercise they would give the brief to
their task unit or their troop or their
platoon and you know us training cadre
would sit there and we'd take notes and
say okay this is a bad part of the plan
hey you should have thought about this
hey this won't really work you know so
we'd give them critiques and then and
you know I would go last you know
because I was the guy in charge so they
let me go last so everyone kind of you
know there be two or three guys that
would kind of pick apart the plan and
then I would go and mention maybe you
know four or five other things right
because my guys would cover most of them
so these guys get up and they're briefly
briefed this new mission and how they're
gonna execute this new mission and they
go okay you know where they wrap up
their mission and now we got the
leadership in there to debrief them on
their on their brief and my guys like
didn't have anything and and so they get
to me and I was like okay here's what's
going on boom boom and I just rattled
off like 19 things and the the senior
enlisted guy that was there we
done and we walked out and he was like
when you leave no one's gonna be able
dance and and I was like no man he's
just but but when I think about what
just occurred what occurred during that
time all I was doing was taking what I
knew already what what my senior
listening I knew as well
I just overlaid it he didn't overlaid it
look it didn't look the same so he
wasn't quite sure so I just overlaid
what I knew and said oh yeah here's
here's what doesn't make sense because
guess what cover move still applies
decentralized command staff is
we want to keep it simple that's all of
us prioritize and execute still applies
whoo that's those things the terrain
taking advantage of the terrain that
still applies so even though the mission
has a totally different name the
fundamental principles don'ts don't
change so if you can take an overlay
what you know you're gonna do well and
that's actually that's actually what
good leaders do what good leaders they
take what they know about humans oh I've
worked with a guy like that before you
know it's funny we do our role-playing
people and one of the characters that we
talk about in our roleplay at Ashkelon
front one of the characters that we talk
about is a grumpy old Arnold right
grumpy old Arnold who's been doing this
for 25 years and he's really good he's
really respected and and he likes to do
things his way and he doesn't like you
know he doesn't like being told what to
do and when we whenever we bring up this
character that I I made up but of course
like I made it up but everybody says oh
is this based on my company so everybody
has an Arnold and then we go to the next
role play and the next role play is you
know this guy who's you know young buck
and what's Young Buck like young buck is
super fired up and he's just ready to go
get after it but he also doesn't like
following what the rules are because the
rules are impeding his progress and if
it goes oh yeah we got young buck over
here we're actually said it's so funny
like at the muster walk around with
people they go this is yo yeah the years
are older we all you know it's always
funny it's always good but what good
leaders do is they they take now now
when someone says hey this is Arnold or
hey we have an Arnold that it's not
exactly the same but you can certainly
overlay some of the knowledge that you
have
to that person you can't overlay it
completely because that's a mistake as a
leader it's a mistake to treat Arnold
this Arnold the same as that Arnold
because they have the same some similar
characteristics but they're not the same
and what you did with this one won't
work may not necessarily work with that
one you're gonna have to modulate it a
little bit and so what you do as a
leader if you can take and you can
overlay your knowledge on two situations
that you haven't seen before but you
recognize what similarities there are
and how to how to handle those scenarios
that's gonna make you infinitely better
Oh totally in the thousands of flights
that I had in my career no two are
exactly the same I never had two flights
that are exactly the same
and that's would any insert any job
anything we've ever done nothing is
exactly the same and I've had that same
experience of people saying this is that
guy that your desire Arnold or this is
our Young Buck but if you if as a leader
you start getting more and more success
we kind of racking up wins and you start
to get fair that out and you think that
you know how everything is going to play
out that that's a kill or two and we we
had in aviation we have we checked
mishap rates which obviously no expense
of airplanes and airplane scratches
catastrophic and there's two spikes in a
person's career that mishap rates and
one is about the 200 to 300 hour range
which is really literally just learning
to fly an airplane so it stands a reason
a lot of people crash airplanes when
their first one we had a fly and then
after about 500 hours that mishap rate
falls really low and then there's a very
very low mishap rate and then and then
it spikes again and it spikes at about
the 2000 hour mark and that's a really
experienced squadron commander kind of
level really experienced and it's
because they fall into that trap was
they I've seen it all and the reality is
that some of those things never change
actually the principles they never
change but the outcomes are always
moving around and that buck that's here
it's different than buck over there and
when you get complacent think I've got
this figured out same thing happens in
aviation that's where the mishaps go up
again and it's the same thing for a
leader as recognizing that all these
problems are different all these
problems are the same but you do not
know the outcome
do not know the outcome that's that's
that that is like a fire in my brain
every problem that I look at I'm
simultaneously looking at it at the same
time I'm saying okay I think I've seen
this before I also have a louder voice
my head that's saying you don't actually
know you don't actually know anything
you should actually just be quiet yes
and then try and figure this thing out
because you don't know so that's
definitely right and you can see when
people get to that 2,000 hour mark they
start to think they've got it all
figured out and that's not gonna be good
overlay your knowledge next section is
called how we view combat and how we
fight how we view combat how we view the
combat environment in large part
determines how we operate in it there
are two competing views of combat some
see it in simple terms as if the battle
and the environment represented a closed
mechanical system this deterministic
view argues that combat is predictable
among the advocates of this view our
military theorists who seek prescriptive
rules for battle and analysts who
predict battle outcomes based upon force
ratio the other view is that combat is
chaotic and uncertain in this problem in
this probabilistic view battle has seen
as complex a complex phenomenon in which
participants interact with one another
and respond and adapt to their
environment the probabilistic viewpoint
sees combat as unpredictable the
distinctions between these two views of
combat are important they drive the
choices commanders make in combat so
this is again I was with a client a new
client the other day exelon front and
meeting the CEO for the first time and
it was interesting he was asking me in a
very positive way in not a negative way
he was asking me in a very curious way
basically the question was well like
like what do you teach what are you what
are you teaching that that that other
people don't teach you know what is it
how how you know there's this high
demand signal at my company for you to
be here and I get it that's why you're
here and I appreciate it but what are
you talking about like what can I expect
to see and you know I said when I ended
up going and doing the kind of the
introduction to the laws of combat and
big stream ownership so he that's when
he kind of when I got done with that he
said oh but I think this is what people
from a leadership perspective if you
have a deterministic viewpoint of
leadership hey when the person does this
oh here's the prescription for that
yeah it doesn't work it doesn't work and
yet that's an easier thing to sell right
if I'm trying to sell you my leadership
instruction the easiest thing reason
well what problems do you have okay well
I'll just tell you what the prescription
for that type of problem is the problem
with the problem that is it's a lot yeah
it doesn't work at all we've been
working on with companies the last
couple years and one of the things that
a lot of companies are doing with is
growth economy is good everybody's
dealing with growth and and I you can
see the difference in the leaders that
have these two different points of view
and the ones that think they have it
kind of have it all figured out this
prescriptive mindset there's nothing in
them that feels like they need to push
and relinquish control down in their
organization because they think they
have the template and they might have
small it started small and they believe
that they can control over them it's a
very its centralized it's just it's at
their core that they they've they're the
leader and they did control things when
there was 27 people and they saw him
every day and they can hey everything
worked awesome yeah it's really you can
do that with a small group especially
the beginning it's it's actually not
that hard to kind of control 15-20
people and as the as it grows
it's those leaders that think that
everything is predetermined by this
matrix this if this then that that that
whole approach they're the ones that are
struggling the most and ironically you
don't see it in the beginning but the
ones that are willing to decentralize
everything and give up the
the ones that actually don't have nearly
as much problem with the growth not
because they know it's all figured out
is because they know that there's no way
I can figure this out and I can't solve
any of these problems by myself and the
best thing they can do is get their
folks when you have a problem here are
some guidance here's some things we do
here's some foundational things that we
do with this company but I actually
don't have the answer for you as a
matter of fact I am not as good as you
are at knowing this particular situation
because you're living in it and every
day I'm off over here doing other things
the leaders that recognize that
everything is chaotic
nothing is predetermined no matter how
good or experienced they are they're the
ones that are the most successful and
the ones that think it's all figured out
they try to control everything and
they're the ones that are most likely to
fail and and from the outside when you
walk in you look and go oh oh all you
have to do is let them let this person
make that decision on their own and it's
gonna work out and if it doesn't he'll
learn from it and he'll figure out the
next time it's easy to see from the
outside you see these two different
leaders it's not just confidence it's
everywhere on the state of approach
absolutely everywhere
it's absolutely everywhere prescriptive
leadership I'm putting that one yeah
yeah in my notebook we're not selling
prescriptions there's own health
leadership health continue on the
deterministic view of combat often leads
to centralized control mmm-hmm it can be
a recipe for micromanagement stifling
the initiative subordinates need to deal
with combats inevitable uncertainties
overly prescriptive orders and plans
inhibit a unit's ability to cope with
uncertainty and change eventually the
unit inflexible and unable to adapt may
be overwhelmed by events and I'll change
that baby over well to who will they be
how's that for deterministic if you have
that if you have that micromanagement
you will end up in a bad situation
the probabilistic view of combat
recognizes that the complexity and
uncertainty of war leads to a more
decentralized approach to control we
place greater trust in subordinates to
achieve the desired result
through the use of mission orders and
commander's intent subordinates are able
to handle unforeseen situations and
exploit opportunities that arise marine
corps tactics
are based on the probabilistic view of
combat must be shocking for some people
to hear that yeah I bet - they have a
totally different people that that did
they just think oh well you know you're
in charge that they boss come in to tell
everyone what to do we must be able to
cope with uncertainty and operate in an
ever-changing combat environment we must
be flexible and responsive to changes in
the situation there are no fixed rules
that can be applied automatically and
every situation is different
that's so legit picture that scene you
described of being an Tarla and all
those you look around your squad leader
is gone your fire team isn't there
anymore your battalion commanders gone
none of the things that you anticipated
prepared or trained for they don't even
exist anymore they're not even there
what are you gonna do now when in this
predetermined preordained coordinated
plan it doesn't work there yeah that is
the the the things that you expected are
literally gone your plan is is
completely evaporated it is nothing the
plan that you had is completely and
utterly gone and if you don't do
anything about that you will be too very
soon there are no fixed rules as one
tactics manual put it more than a half
century ago the leader who frantically
strives to remember what someone else
did in some slightly similar situation
has already set his feet on a
well-traveled road to ruin and that's
actually from the book infantry in
battle so this is so this is where you
have to this is why that overlay that
you put it's it can't block what you see
it's an overlay and for those that don't
know speaking of speaking of just going
old school
yeah in the old days when we used to
have maps and not these incredibly
advanced software programs that put
overlay there so-called overlays but
you'd put a transparent what was that
piece of cellophane or something I got
transparency and you would
are all little things on it and you'd
say okay this is here's the terrain
here's where the targets gonna be and
you can put another overlay that showed
the enemy suspected enemy positions and
you put another overlay that showed your
friendly positions so that's what I'm
talking about you can see through it if
you block it out that's not gonna work
leaders must remember that there are no
fixed rules and no precise checklists
but there are bounds here we get in an
economy that is why successful leaders
study train and exercise their minds to
improve tactical proficiency we study
examples of successes and failures not
to emulate someone else's scheme but to
increase our own tactical understanding
and competence why do we do that why do
we why do we study train and exercise
it's so that we can put those overlays
in our mind and then we can we can
increase our own tactical understanding
and competence next section Marine Corps
tactics the successful execution of
Marine Corps tactics hinges on the
fawful application of a number of
tactical concepts so as to achieve
success on the battlefield key among
these concepts are achieving a decision
a gaining advantage being faster
adapting cooperating and exploiting
success each of these concepts is
discussed in detail later in this
publication creative and practical
employment of these ideas throughout the
planning and execution of tactics leads
to success creative is number one that's
going first yeah that's going first
creative and practical employment of
these ideas throughout the planning and
execution of these tactics leads to
success these concepts are not
standalone ideas but are to be combined
so as to achieve an effect that is
greater than they're separate some part
of the art and science of tactics lies
in knowing where and when to apply these
concepts and which combinations to use
to achieve the desired effect how often
to somebody asked you all what what law
of combat do you think we is most
important for us from like us and it's
like well this one's really important
but guess what you can't get one without
the other right they're all woven
together
the number one definition of these
concepts the number and definition of
these combat concepts are not fixed and
their order of presentation does not
indicate their value
Marines may find in their studies new or
slightly different ideas that may be
just as important these ideas are
presented in this publication so that
readers will think about how to achieve
success on the battlefield I wonder if
the Marines at the basic school and you
went through are afraid to use the word
create I guarantee you I guarantee guess
because the word I'm telling you they
use they they said think for sure and
that's what they meant to be they meant
to be creative and yeah well fine the
word is the word but that's exactly
their what they're getting at us the
answer isn't in this book the answer
isn't that we're gonna go do one week of
combat in the defense and all of a
sudden you've got all the week life
experience you need to be defensive and
come you have to think these concepts
help to provide a framework for
developing a tactical mindset that has
long been the hallmark of marine leaders
from corporal through general and here's
the conclusion two tactics tactile
excellence is the hallmark of a Marine
Corps leader we fight and win in combat
through our mastery of both the art and
science of tactics the art of tactics
involves the creative once again and
innovative once again use of maneuver
warfare concepts while the science of
tactics requires skill and basic war
fighting techniques and procedures for
sure because let's face it if you don't
have the if you don't know the
techniques you can't apply them
creatively you don't even know them
that's right it is our responsibility as
marine leaders to work continuously to
develop our own tactical proficiency and
that of our Marines understanding the
concepts presented in this publication
provides a foundation for that
development
chapter 2 that was one of Saturday and
by the way that's the one chapter be
awesome and we're staring at an over an
hour let's also get some chapter to
achieving a decision it follows then
that the leader who would this is a
quote it follows then that the leader
who would become a competent tactician
must first close his mind to the
alluring formula that well-meaning
people offer in the name of victory to
master his difficult art he must learn
to cut to the heart of a situation
recognize its decisive elements and
bases course of action on these and that
once again that's from this book
infantry battle which infantry battle is
an awesome book and what's really
interesting about infantry in battle and
I'm gonna cover on the podcast probably
I don't know I've got it in the queue
but what's interesting about infantry in
battle of the book is it was written in
nineteen like thirty nine or it came out
in nineteen thirty nine so it's not
based on it's not based on what we
learned in World War two it's what we
did in World War two it's based on World
War one and like these things worked and
these things didn't work they don't they
don't they don't say it that way but
that's basically what it is it's a great
book and there's some and this is when
you see it you see a leader do this cut
to the heart of a situation recognize
its decisive elements and face its
course of action on these that's like
the most pleasurable fantasy ISM as an
observer or as a trooper when you see
someone go ahead here's what's going on
this is what we're gonna do a lot of
people will be talking and almost on the
leader will go hey this is what's
happening this is what we're gonna do
and you go thank God for this guy going
on another quote we must be ruthlessly
opportunistic actively seeking out signs
of weakness against which we will direct
all available combat power when the
decisive opportunity arrived we must
exploit it fully and aggressively
committing every ounce of combat power
we can muster and pushing ourselves to
the limits of exhaustion
which is the way you should actually
live your life as well no big deal
that's from that's from FM FM one
warfighting which I don't know when I
covered that on this podcast but it was
like podcast five or something like that
so yes ruthlessly opportunistic fully
and aggressively that's what I'm talking
about and also recognizing that the
number of times you're gonna get that
opportunity to exploit something to win
it might be once in a battle yeah it
might be once and that window may last
for minutes it may last an hour it may
last a day but it might be gone yeah and
when you see it you're gonna have to
step and you have to make that decision
and there's gonna be risk in that
decision and you're not guaranteed an
outcome in any way shape or form but
here's the counterpoint
if you don't maneuver well that
opportunity can be lost yeah and and
there this is a there's a huge
discussion about the dichotomy I don't
use the word dichotomy but they
definitely talk about it all the time
just because we're saying you got to be
opportunistic and take advantage of
those things that doesn't mean that you
just run to your death doesn't mean to
charge into every bunker that you see
because you think it's the decisive
bunker no we talk about this all the
time even I think you know the the
dichotomy that comes in here the idea of
being brave but not foolhardy and and
then you even talked about it in QA
recently about recognizing the being
default aggressive obviously that's a
really good thing but but you can't be
like that all the time because if you're
over-aggressive and you exploit the
wrong opportunity or you or you're
actually so aggressive that you haven't
had a chance to bring all your forces to
bear when it actually is most effective
that's every bit as destructive as being
so disconnected or being so unaggressive
that you miss those opportunities as
well and the answer like you said it
always it's it's in that middle and just
saying be aggressive that doesn't solve
your problems you actually have to know
when to do that I don't know if you that
the podcast I was talking about when I
started thinking about that I thought to
be leadership this was a big deal
because because what I had to do to to
come up with that to allow my brain to
get around that I had to say that I was
right you're wrong yeah then I was wrong
like this isn't right also it's not
always good to be aggressive it's not
always good to go forward it's like all
those things it's not always good to
step up and lead all the time no
actually it's not there's some times
when you should fall like for me to sit
there and I remember it was one of those
situated this is what we just talked
about there was some time when I was
watching something unfold and the the
thought was well they should have been
more aggressive and I was like that's
what I want to say cuz that's what big
tough Jocko says but guess what that's
not the right answer
mm-hmm the right answer is actually that
would have been the wrong time to be
aggressive and they actually did a good
job by sitting back and letting that
situation develop so what is this and I
just thinking about this in my head you
know what is going on here oh because
you can't be too aggressive you can't be
dressed up all the time oh and by the
way there's every trait that you look at
yeah there's a counter to it and if you
go too far with any of them you're wrong
for sure and that's why the things that
we teach we don't teach the answers of
saying oh your answer is B default
aggressive that that by itself doesn't
work so you actually have to understand
not just what it means but when to do
that and know that there is actually an
unlimited at that it will become
ineffective if you're just I'm
aggressive that's how I lead get on
board and and that you lead your team to
destruction because you're thinking oh I
got to be aggressive yes you do but you
have to actually have to know when to be
aggressive and actually sometimes the
best thing is to be the exact opposite
of that and let the situation unfold
until you see that opportunity yeah and
I mean did its flanking right flanking
is an aggressive movement but it's not
as aggressive as charging up the middle
right the frontal assault frontal
assault is more aggressive they give you
credit but it's not going to work out
better that's right and then the other
funny thing from a leadership
perspective is hey am I
am I being weak am i being fearful if I
don't if I'm not aggressive but here's
the answer and this is a real simple way
to look at it when when you deal with
another human being
are you building the relationship or are
you breaking it are you are you moving
it forward are you moving it back yeah
that's the question and and the answer
is the answer the answer is if you're if
what if I'm gonna have a conversation
with you and it's gonna move our
relationship forward
cool that's probably the right answer if
I'm gonna have a conversation with you
and it's gonna move our relationship
backwards that's probably not the right
answer so if you leave if if you came up
with a bad plan and my approach with you
on that is hey Dave your plan sucked and
I don't think you're cut out for this or
hey your plan sucks and I don't I'm
gonna you have to use my plan now which
would both of those have a negative
outcome both of those you're looking at
me going okay so Jocko doesn't trust me
he did he doesn't think my plan is any
good instead of me going hey man can you
explain to me I won't understand like
how you're gonna execute this thing
because it's important for me to
understand what you're thinking so I can
give you the support that you need can
you can you kind of walk me through your
your thought process and how this is
gonna go down well that what does that
do with our relationship now you're
gonna explain something to me I'm gonna
subtly and smoothly point out the little
mistakes in the plan that you had and
I'm gonna actually let you come to the
conclusion that you know what hands not
if I'm actually gonna change this a
little bit and then I go oh wow I would
have never caught that and boom all of a
sudden our relationship got stronger so
yes there's a dichotomy there is and
there's actually there actually is a
time sometimes that the frontal assault
does work that's why there's a frontal
assault absolutely if it never worked it
wouldn't be a thing absolutely but the
time and the place to do that first of
all it's a lot less common than people
think the frontal assault should be the
exception by a huge margin but there are
times that the frontal assault works and
sometimes when the
frontal assault with another person the
times that it is most effective is when
you've spilt spent a lifetime and built
a lifetime of a relationship that you
can go Dave
this is stupid we're not doing it and I
go okay yeah and I trust you and I don't
get defensive and I don't shrink back
down because I'm cashing in are you
cashing in on a lifetime of not having
done if you over and over again I'm I'm
gonna just roll over when you say that
and I'm it's gonna make it worse for me
but there are times that actually the
frontal assault does work for sure and
it only works when you've not done it a
thousand times that the one time it
happens the guy is willing to listen
what's being said yeah and there's
there's other times where the phone on
assault is good and the frontal assault
can be good because you're setting up
other avenues of approach actually
followed yeah yeah yeah sure there's
I've I've used that approach some time
where I've gone ballistic about
something that wasn't a big deal but
what I was really doing was prepping the
battlefield for something something else
so yeah there's maneuvers that have to
happens for sure moving back to the book
tactics is the employment of units in
combat the objective of tactics is to
achieve military success through a
decision in battle using tactical
actions to achieve a decision is central
to marine corps tactics in the past
military forces have also have often won
only incremental gains when they thought
when they sought victory taking a hill
here or a town there pushing the front
forward a few kilometres or adding to
the body count
sometimes these incremental gains were
the result of a competent enemy or the
chaotic nature of war meaning what
they're saying there is like sometimes
you're only making these incremental
gains because the enemy is super
competent or nature is crazy okay so we
get that that can happen and then it
continues many times however commanders
saw incremental gains as a means to
achieve victory think about that you're
looking at the battlefield and you go
you know what we're gonna get this house
we're gonna get that house right there
and we're gonna do wall no matter what
we're gonna get that house and you're
not looking at this whole battlefield
this whole city this whole region this
whole province so we look at these
little
practical incremental gains as a means
to achieve victory this incrementalist
view sees war as a slow cumulative
process and it is best and is best
exemplified by the grinding attrition
tactics seen on the Western Front in
World War one there the opponents were
more or less evenly matched and their
tactics resulted in in decisive action
in Vietnam where the Cape where the
opposing forces were quite dissimilar in
their military capabilities both the
incremental approach led to the us's
over reliance on fire power and body
counts this in turn led to the conduct
of military operations that were often
irrelevant to the outcome of war even
though a comparison of cash the ratio
ratios appeared favorable think about
that you're conducting operations that
were irrelevant on the outcome of the
war how often do I see that in
leadership in businesses in life people
are doing things that are relevant to
the outcome of the war and committing so
much time and so many resources to that
and so much individual human stress yeah
the body-count thing in Vietnam you know
the more I learn about that the more the
the it's such a clear mistake when you
look at it from from now right with our
hindsight and I was just reading an
article the other day from a Vietnam guy
was like yeah Lee he's again I think we
killed two we reported 20 like that was
because that way hey you know everyone
get the pat on the back no one else
knows no one cares and how many how many
platoon commanders did that well every
platoon in the company so it was 60
there was 60 we killed 60 and guess what
even if we did kill 60 guess what the
Vietcong didn't care
yeah they were there for the long war
yeah but on some spreadsheets sixty
means we're winning yep yep 60 versus we
took two casualties school we're gonna
we're gonna beat him we're gonna win yep
back to the book therefore the Marine
Corps has embraced a more flexible
imaginative and effective way to wage
war maneuver warfare that is the way you
should picture everything that you do in
your life it should be maneuver warfare
marine success with this approach has
been demonstrated in places like Grenada
and the Persian Gulf in contrast to
tactics based on an incremental
attrition tactics and maneuver warfare
always aim at decisive action that's
what you want year that's what you want
to be looking for this is what echo
Charles refers to as the long war he
says well I mean he doesn't work he
doesn't refer to that place but he says
that that's the biggest thing that he's
learned and if he wishes he knew one
thing from sitting in here for all these
hours listening to me he wishes that he
knew he wishes that he understood the
long war at a younger age for sure I
feel I think everybody probably feels
like that I certainly feel like that and
the reason life mirrors that is because
that life is life life as a campaign
life is life is as long as it is and you
have maybe in life you might have four
or five culminating events in your life
you might get if you get lucky you just
get a handful of those and if you miss
those if you don't if you're not aware
that you're working towards those you'll
do what a lot of people do is look back
and say boy I wish I had dot whatever
that is and that recognition that it's
the same thing as that campaign and you
have to actually everything you do
affects something else and you need to
be working towards whatever that
culminating event is and if you're lucky
you get a few and if you miss him you
spent a lifetime looking back wishing
you hadn't and in combat if you miss a
culminating event you can lose you you
can lose you can lose your guys you can
lose the war you can you can lose
everything you and I were with a client
and I actually I actually like we were
with a dad with him for a day and I was
like gonna close out the day and I had
like some little thing that I had talked
about at the end of the day
and as soon as I got done I realized I
wish I would have said something else
and here's what I would have said
because it's we you and I were reading
the service and one of the things that
we read on the service someone said hey
this training because you'd work with
his client before someone said hey the
training with you know Dave was cool but
it was kind of like seeing a Rocky movie
and at the end of a rocky movie
everybody wants to go in and box and
train and work out and then two days
later you're not doing any of those
things and I what I should have done and
I hate me as soon as I walked up said
she's just one of those bad timings I
should have said hey I should have
brought up those surveys and said I'm
gonna read you what someone said and
what someone said is this is like a
Rocky movie and everyone wants a trained
boxing and then two days later you're
back to normal
and I said I said the person who ever
wrote that in this room and I'm not
gonna call you out whoever wrote that is
a hundred percent right you are a
hundred percent right because this is
not an inoculation you're we know you're
gonna be fired up but you know what it
takes to change leadership inside of a
company is not one brief or two briefs
from Dave what it takes it's a campaign
that you have to think about every
single day you have to think about the
long more you're not gonna go
you can sit through a three-hour
briefing and expect that oh now well now
our leadership is good to go no it's not
like that it's a campaign that you have
to get on you have to think about it
every day you have to train it every day
and actually the same group we had done
some physical training with them in the
morning you know we put them through
like a PT program I should have said
okay now that we did that PT this
morning for 40 minutes who is now in
good shape and no one want to raise
their hand and I would have said that's
right just because you sat through three
hours with Dave and I does this mean
that your your leadership is now honed
and sharp no not true just like you have
to continue to workout every day you
have to continue to train and study
every single day you have to continue to
be reflective and look at yourself and
see and look at your peers and talked
each other and see what you can prove
and see what you can do better that's
what you need to do so yes in two days
you're you're gonna be back to normal if
you allow yourself to be but if you get
in the game and if you see this as a
campaign and if you see this as or
working out that you need to do every
single day and if you look at yourself
for the mistakes that you're making as a
leader and what mistakes your
organization is making as leaders that
is when you will become better and you
can become a champion just like Rocky
unfortunately I thought of it like three
like literally fifteen seconds after I
walked off but um you know that and what
I told them was similar but it wasn't
the same Ram wasn't the same so yeah I
remember I remember that conversation
and and it also gets to the point too
that no matter where you are in an
organization you actually can have a
massive influence from that position if
you if you do that you don't have to be
the CEO of a company to steer the
company in a particular direction and if
you actually recognize okay maybe not
today maybe not turn on but if I get on
this path and I stay on this path I'm
gonna start to cultivate a little more
influence I'm gonna get more success I'm
gonna and eventually you can be the
driving force behind the organization of
the team being successful yes at any
level yes you can you have so much more
just like you have so much more
ownership of things like in your world
yeah people people don't realize how
much control and power they have over
their life okay I get it the ders
exceptions I get it that there's
horrible diseases I get it that there's
accidents that I get it I get it and and
it's the sympathy and empathy that I
feel for those situations absolutely I
get it there's also so much that you
have control over in your life so you
have this impact of your life it's the
same thing in an or in an organization
you think I'm just a middle manager or
I'm just a frontline soldier okay let's
see what happens let's see what happens
if you get in the game I'll tell you
what happens al gray
amen he started off as whatever he won
in the United States Marine Corps that's
what I'm talking about how did he do
that by sitting back and complaining and
pointing his finger to other people no
by stepping up and making things happen
that's how you do it Hackworth young kid
enlisted kid what'd he do sit back and
complain or sit back and say he didn't
have any control no he stepped up took
ownership of things made things happen
got a battlefield commission you can
make these things happen whether you get
a battlefield commission or not you can
make these things happen I just see that
all the time where I was when I was on
that training there be a if there's a
platoon was like weak leadership like
weak platoon commander a weak platoon
chief and it happens but there be some
pipe hit and E 5 in there just a hard
dog and he would have good leadership
skills and he'd I had one kid he was
such a beast and but he wasn't like
lettin it out they were going through
their urban training and they're all
pinned down and the leaders are making
no decisions and I walk over this kid
he's pinned down behind the wall if like
I saw and I'm like I'm like hey bro
and he's like what's up sir and I was
like you're just gonna sit here and left
all this happen he's like well he kind
of like what do you mean and I said make
something happen bro you know what to do
and the the the the light in his eyes as
he just started to get some and that's
all it takes somebody step up and lead
so it doesn't matter where you are in
that organization if you if you look at
where you're at if you look at where you
want to go long term you'll get there
you will have him but then it's not
gonna be easy man there was things that
I fought for in the SEAL Teams that I
took years and years and years and some
of my wasn't successful completely I
planted seeds that are still trying to
take root but that's what you got to do
back to the book this does not mean
however that combat should be viewed as
a bloodless ballet of movement I should
have read that in the fridge before us
this does not mean however that combat
should be viewed as a bloodless ballet
of movement combat especially at the
tactical level of war will be
characterized by tough brutal and
desperate engagements we must remember
that war is a violent clash of two
opposing wills in which each side is
trying to wrest advantage from the other
our future enemies may not allow us to
gain maintain or employ technological or
numerical superiority the future battle
may be bloody and tough and that makes
it vitally important that we marine
leaders strive to develop tactical
proficiency what do we mean by achieving
a decision take a moment to compare
these two historical examples Anzio a
model of tactical indecisiveness late
1943 the Allies were searching for a way
to alleviate the stalemate in Italy the
campaign installed around the casino
Wharf the casino front and resembled the
trench war trench warfare of World War 1
in order to keep pressure on the Germans
bypassed the stubborn German defenses at
Cassino and capture Rome a bold
operation was envisioned the US Army's
3rd division and the British Army's 1st
division would make an amphibious
landing at Anzio about 35 miles south of
Rome the Allies achieved complete
surprise by landing at Anzio On January
22nd 1944 under the command of the US
Army's Major General Lucas the Americans
and British quickly established a
beachhead and rapidly advanced 3 miles
inland by mid-morning against light
German resistance with the majority of
their forces concentrated further south
around Cassino the Germans could not
possibly reinforce the Anzio beachhead
until the January 23rd to 24th if the
Allies press their advantage the road to
Rome lay virtually undefended the
seizure of Rome would have had the
effect of isolating the German defenders
in the south and firmly establishing
allied control over Italy
pretty straightforward situation
general Lucas delayed concerned about
being overextended and wanting to build
up his logistic sister or Lucas failed
to press his initial advantage of
surprise and allow the Germans to
reinforce the Anzio area not until
January 29th did Lucas feel strong
enough to make an offensive bid but by
that time it was too late the Germans
had arrived in force and had seized the
dominating high ground in the beachhead
area not only was the Allied offensive
at Anzio stalled with the Germans it
seized the initiative and quickly
threatened to drive the Americans and
British back into the sea as a result
the Allies did not complete the
reduction of German defenses in southern
Italy and capture Rome until several
months later general Lucas lost a
tremendous opportunity to exploit an
initial success and gain a decisive
result it's pretty straightforward yeah
it's it's easy to sit here - and be like
cool no I obviously would have just
pushed homework right there's and that's
what you've got to think about you got
to think about okay what what did he see
you know and how much intelligence did
he have he might not have known all this
that being said this is one of those
situations where you go look we just
made it ashore pretty easily we've got
we're doing pretty good the Germans
aren't in position yet and you'd figure
that out pretty quickly and let me tell
you something else here's here's what my
mentality would have been the Germans
okay let's say we don't know 100% that
the Germans aren't set up on us right
how are we gonna find out you know I'm
gonna find out I'm gonna go yeah not
sitting here alive I'm not gonna sit
here and wait I'm gonna find out I'm
gonna push forward I guess what if we
push forward and we meet massive
resistance that requires this extensive
logistic train that I'm waiting for cool
guess what it looks like we're gonna
wait for it but if I push start to push
through and all of a sudden I realize
that that we get through well guess what
cool we're gonna move a little bit
further and I'm gonna continue push you
know I talked about been talking a lot
about this incremental decision-making
idea and that's a great example right
it's not okay we landed we're gonna go
straight to Rome but guess what we
landed we're three miles in guess what
we're going to do too
we're gonna go five miles in I guess
we're gonna do the day after that or you
a seven miles in oh and by the way if we
start to see like an open road we're
gonna go until we meet some resistance
so I'm not committing a hundred percent
day one because we don't know what we're
up against we don't know because if we
run out of ammunition we're screwed we
get that so I'm gonna make these
incremental decisions that are gonna
lead me toward my final objective but
it's gonna it's going to prevent me from
getting stagnant and waiting and not
gaining any new information because when
we're sitting still we're not getting
any new information in a matter of fact
the enemy's maneuvering I said at all
the time if you're sitting still the
enemy's maneuvering on you here's a
classic example and what do you think
the Nazis are gonna do for the Nazis
aren't gonna maneuver on you right these
are the blitzkrieg people remember them
yeah what we're not sitting back and
waiting for this to happen we need to go
forward in the obviously again you know
this is all for us we can sit here in
hindsight and listen to this and read
this and recognize that but that's with
the first two pages of this book that's
the leaders job is to recognize that
when you have those culminating events
when you have the opportunity you have
to see it and you bring all your forces
to bear to attack that now that doesn't
mean that you just get on line and push
in this case you just push the third
column that's not what it means but it
means that this is our time to take the
things that we have the all the things
available to us to do that and we we get
aggressive when we attack in it and what
I'm saying is I'm actually giving away a
pragmatic tool that you can technically
use whate because I'm not saying you we
can look back and say hey the decision
should've been this or this what I'm
saying if here's a pragmatic tool that
you can use as a leader which is the
following you see an opening press press
you don't need to go crazy now you press
it and you evaluate yeah and you see
what happens and that were V and
actually that's a better chance to
reveal what's actually happening then
not pressing which is different than
everybody get online and run that's not
what I'm saying but we move to the next
one and the best intelligence you're
gonna get is that the point of friction
and if it's there's not a lot of
friction here
good keep there's way more friction than
we expected or can deal with them now we
know and
she respond to that as well
another example Kenai a clear tactical
decision achieved on August 2nd
216 BC the Carthaginian general Hannibal
fought the Roman army under the command
of Teheran tina's tarantia s' Varro near
the city of Kenai in southern Italy
Hannibal based his tactics on the
specific characteristics of both forces
and on the aggressive personality of the
Roman commander Oh I highlighted that in
my notes because listen that Han will
base his tactics on the specific
characteristics of both forces and on
the aggressive personality of the Roman
commander he knows for his mark he knows
that that dude likes to get aggressive
yeah cool I got you pegged
here we go has dawn broke Hannibal drew
up his force of 50,000 veterans with his
flank with his left flank anchored on
the a Faddis River secured from
envelopment by the more numerous Romans
so he got on your left flank you're
protected you got a river there great
his centerline contained only a thin
line of infantry his main force was
concentrated on the flanks his his left
and right wings each contained deep vein
Lance's of heavy infantry 8,000 cavalry
tied to his left line to the river are
tied his left line to the river 2,000
cavalry protected his open right flank
8,000 men guarded his camp in the rear
Varro and more than 80,000 Romans so
they're not numbered by Hannibal's
outnumbered by 30,000 Varro and more
than a thousand Romans accepted the
challenge
seeing the well-protected Carthaginian
flanks Varro dismissed any attempt to
envelop he decided to crush his opponent
by sheer weight of numbers he placed
65,000 men in his Center 2,400 cavalry
on his right 4800 Calvary on this left
and sent 11,000 men in to attack the
Carthaginian camp following preliminary
skirmish this Hannibal moved his light
center line forward to a salient against
the Roman center and when they say
salient that's like a it's like a it's
like a projection it's like a
that's gonna move forward it's like a
point almost like a point element but
it's a big point element then his heavy
Calvary on the left crushed the opposing
Roman cavalry and swung completely
around the Roman to Roman rear to attack
the Roman cavalry on the other flank the
Roman cavalry fled the field the
Carthaginian heavy Cavill T cavalry then
turned back to assault the rear of the
defense the rear of the dense Roman
infantry who had pressed back Hannibal's
thin center line at the same time
Hannibal wheeled his right and left
wings into the flanks the Roman center
the Romans were boxed in unable to
maneuver or use their weapons
effectively between 50,000 and 60,000
Romans died that day as Varro's army was
destroyed so battle the psalm had 60,000
casualties in one day
this is 60,000 dead know your opponent
don't be this is don't be over
aggressive - faro was over aggressive
rossik i see a thin line watch this
yeah watch this is right understanding
decisiveness what did these examples
tell us about achieving a decision first
achieving decision is important and
indecisive but a battle wastes the lives
of those who fight it and die in it it
wastes the efforts of those who survive
as well all the costs the deaths the
wounds the sweat and effort the
equipment destroyed are used up the
supplies expended are suffered for
little gain such battles have no meaning
except for the comparative losses and
perhaps an incremental gain for one side
or the other I've been talking about
being a black belt in jujitsu and how a
black belt in jujitsu when you grab
something that doesn't matter if they
don't care what they want is the
decisive thing that's what they want
they want the decisive position they
want the decisive movement and that's
the difference and that's what they're
talking about here you when you do
things that are indecisive that they're
not a they're not gonna they're not
gonna make or break the battle that's
what's happening it's not gonna make or
break the battle it's just you're just
wasting wasting energy wasting in the
Indian war you're wasting human
you're wasting equipment and you're
wasting ammunition and supplies and for
a liter think about what that means when
you do things that waste your people's
times and certainly in this case waste
their lives obviously that's an extreme
situation but even just wasting their
efforts when you do things that waste
their effort over time your credibility
as a leader and even your opportunity to
be successful in the long run every
single time you do that it goes down and
that failure to recognize that this
tactical thing we're gonna stay late to
do this one thing because this thing
needs to happen and there are times it's
actually true but there are times that
if you continually waste your people's
efforts eventually recognize you
actually don't care about what it is
that we're doing and over time your
credibility's leader goes away because
you don't recognize that these tactical
things you're trying to get solved are
all leading you down towards in this
case the destruction of an army yeah and
here's what you just said I'm gonna add
something you said you don't care about
what we're doing and what's even gonna
drive these people into a worse
situation from a leadership perspective
is they're gonna realize that you don't
care about them you don't care about
them and y'all haven't done a good job
when when General mukogawa was on MOOC
he put this massive emphasis on caring
about your people and like making sure
they understand and if you you cuz when
you asked him why he loved Hackworth so
much it's like Oh cuz Hackworth cared
care about me yeah so the most important
thing the most important thing is like
oh yeah wait we I get I'm definitely
concerned about what we're doing the
most important thing I care about is you
troops now we have a mission to do and
by the way the mission that we're gonna
do is gonna benefit us all of us in the
long run because when we win this war
our kids don't have to go to Warren
we're gonna have stability we're gonna
have security and that's what our goal
is so it benefits us and there's gonna
be sacrifice in the short term but
that's what we're here to do we're not
here to make any sacrifices that aren't
required at all ever that's the most
important thing I care about you my
troops I care about
you I want you to win I want you to
survive I want you to be taken care of
and we have a mission to do and we're
gonna do it but the minute that but the
mission benefits you as well right it's
not just hey you're gonna die for me no
that's not what we're talking about at
all we're gonna put our lives at risk
because we have something we're trying
to accomplish that's gonna benefit each
and every one of our families in our
lives in our country that that idea in
business and that idea is so important
that belief that that you care about
your people so much that they recognize
at a point that they would be willing to
do anything for you and it doesn't mean
you don't ask your people to go do hard
things it doesn't mean you don't put
them in very difficult situations by
which their lives might actually be lost
that's not what it means to care about
you means I don't put you at risk
sometimes I actually do put you at risk
but if a leader and it's not just a it's
actually believing if the leader
actually believes that his people are
that important and as a subordinate if I
work for someone and go home we got this
guy actually he he cares about me that
much I would literally be willing to do
anything for that person but it actually
comes from that understanding that this
person I worked for he doesn't just care
about the mission being accomplished for
the mission sake or even for his own
sake that he recognizes actually in my
best interest that's a rare thing that's
what cultivates young Marines or young
people willing to do anything for you
and leaders get that backwards all the
time they don't they recognize that they
fail to recognize their the thing that
will allow them to do the hardest things
they need to do is by having those
people believe in them that much yeah
I'm gonna put a an actual quantifiable
amount because you you you just said it
twice you said that much you said the
leader cares about you that much you
said it sort of in the beginning of your
statement and you just said it at the
end I'm gonna quantify what that much
means because it's really easy to do the
way you quantify how much a leader has
to cook care how much is it it's the
leader cares
more about the person than they do about
themselves and if that's what the troops
see if that's what they see that's when
you get as you said young Marines young
or employees or soldiers sailors airmen
Marines
linemen construction guys manufacturing
people whoever it is when they see that
they will know and that that then they
will go that extra distance for you
hey is it every single one of those guys
know these you've got people that are
self-centered and then we're gonna look
at you and go cool I'm gonna take
advantage of this guy that happens it
does happen you got him you got to be
where you got to not even be aware of it
you just need to understand it for sure
but that's what you need to do and you
can't fake that that no you can't fake
that that make know me there that as a
leader is something you have to believe
you have to believe that feeling of they
are actually more important then you
know those things in some places come
very naturally with your kids that comes
naturally but you can't fake that and
they will see right through that and
that that feeling as a leader that's
hard but it's actually it's possible I
have worked for people that I've come to
realize they care about me more than
them they are willing to endure more of
themselves for my benefit and it's
almost always the other way around and
those people those few times I've worked
people for people like that I would
literally do anything anything for that
person jerk
second achieving a decision is not easy
history is littered with indecisive
battle sometimes it was enemy's skill
and determination that preventive it
even a victorious commander from
achieving the decision he sought in
other cases commanders fought a battle
without envisioning a larger result for
their actions again this is long war
sometimes even with a vision of making
the decisive battle decisive they cannot
achieve their goals
due to the chaos and friction that is
the nature of war and makes decisive
victories so difficult that leads to the
third lesson our examples point out to
be decisive a battle or an engagement
must lead to a result beyond itself must
lead to a result beyond itself within a
battle an action that is decisive must
lead directly to winning in the campaign
or war as a whole for the battle to be
decisive it must lead directly to a
larger success in the war as a whole
don't really even need to comment on
that except for to say how often do
people and businesses do things and
fight battles they fight battles that
have no bearing and no result beyond the
battle itself
you see people shooting themselves all
the time with this very idea they're
gonna win that war they're gonna win
that argument with their wife right oh
yeah they're gonna win that battle what
does it lead to they're gonna leave
they're gonna win that argument with
their subordinate or they're gonna win
that argument with their boss where is
it lead them oh yeah look that worked
out great for you it actually sets you
back in your campaign you don't think
about that though
on the other hand we must not seek
decisiveness for its own sake oh but
boom dichotomy coming at you we do not
after all seek a decision if it is like
me to be against us
we seek to ensure in so far as this is
possible given the inherent
uncertainties of war that the battle
will go our way we have stacked the deck
in our favor before the cards are laid
on the table otherwise to seek decisive
bomb battle isn't irresponsible gamble
if you're if you see me Jocko if you see
me engaged with someone I already know
the outcome like when I'm talking when
I'm discussing someone something I
already know the outcome because I've
already laid that out in my head
otherwise I'm just listening to you I'm
just gonna listen to you because I'm
learning and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
step on to the battlefield right I'll
talk to you and we'll discuss
possibilities and outcomes and plans and
that's that's great I will not take a
stand until I actually know what the
outcome is gonna be just FYI and you've
done all the things that you need to do
prior to that up to including that
conversation yes to know what that is
yes because if not then you're just
arguing for argument argument sake and
then you might win the argument which is
great only it won't actually help you in
the long run exactly when we seek battle
we must seek victory accomplishment of
the assigned mission that leads to
further significant gains for the force
as a whole at Anzio the Allied aim was
to break the stalemate in the south
opening up a southern front that would
force Germany to move additional forces
from the defense of Normandy this
weakening of Normandy defenses would
support our planned invasion of France
later that same year at Kani Carthage
won Carthage won one round in its long
contention with Rome for the domination
of the Mediterranean these tactical
battles were planned for their overall
operational strategic effect the
consequences of a tactical engagement
should lead to achieving operational and
strategic goals
please everyone please don't fight
battles unless they're gonna help you
win strategically yeah the battle for
the battles sake doesn't help you and in
those examples - we're not doing an
amphibious landing on Tarawa to do an
infix landing on Tarawa
we're doing a FEMINIST landing on taro
at establish a beachhead specifically so
the next the final thing we do is push
the enemy off the island or kill and
it's that saying that we got here we
establish we accomplish this mission and
this this practical thing this battle
that's actually not what we're doing
yeah that's a step in in fact we're not
even just pushing him off taro that's
not the goal the goal isn't push them
out there all four years down there yeah
absolutely all those two years down the
road the goal is we're gonna put a we're
gonna put airplanes here that we can
then bomb Japan that's what we're doing
yes next section military judgment once
we understand what is meant by the term
decisive and why is it important to seek
a decision a question naturally arises
how do we do it there is no easy answer
to that question each battle will have
its own unique answers as with so much
in warfare it depends on the situation
no formula process acronym or buzzword
can provide the answer no formula
process acronym or buzzword can provide
the answer
rather the and you wouldn't guess that
if you saw if you saw if you go online
even with you even what they do with
like me they'll do an article on me
three things a leader needs dudes well
yeah there's three that's definitely
three those are three yeah there's three
but guess what you need to actually
learn the art behind the science rather
the answer is in military judgment then
the ability of the commander to
understand the battlefield and act
decisively military judgment is - is a
developed skill that is honed by the
wisdom gained through experience
combined with situational awareness
military judgment allows us to identify
emerging patterns discern critical
vulnerabilities and concentrate combat
power the beauty of that is the Marine
Corps the Marine Corps understands that
those traits that
of judgment that attribute of
decisiveness those can be developed
those can be learned those aren't just
innate natural capacity that we just
happen to bring these people into the
Marine Corps that's one of the traits
that the Marine Corps recognizes that we
have to teach people to learn
decisiveness and teach people the
quality of judgment and they breed that
in their Marines and they train and
teach them now look yes some are better
than others no doubt about it but these
qualities these things and we're talking
about how important these are not just
in the military but in the private
sector
these can be learned these can be
evolved and developed inside everybody
to what degree is certainly different
but everybody can get better at this
almost everybody true right yeah no
you're right absolutely and I I'm
speaking in absolutes and everybody and
really what I should be saying is not
just I shouldn't say it that everybody
has to say almost everybody but I should
say we have so much more capacity to
evolve these things than we think we do
yeah and by the way just in case no one
was paying attention to what I've been
saying for the last 25 years when I say
almost everybody the almost the person
that I can't teach this to the person
that can't improve their military
judgment is the person that already
thinks they have go says I don't know is
it all yeah is the person that thinks
that they already have the wisdom that
that person they're not gonna get any
better in fact they're gonna get worse
because they'll reinforce their ideas so
if you have an open mind you can get way
better at this stuff yeah if you don't
have an open mind you won't get any
better understanding the situation the
first requirement of commanders to
understand the situation you would think
that that was just so off so
self-evident yeah
that you wouldn't even say in the book
but how often am i dealing with a leader
military civilian another human being
just going through life they don't even
understand the situation that they're
and that's why we have to save this out
loud in a book the first requirement of
commanders to understand the situation
the successful tactician studies the
situation to develop in his mind a clear
picture of what is happening how it got
that way and how it might develop
further considering the factors of
mission enemy terrain and whether troops
and support available
this has met met t the commander must
think through all actions determine the
desired result and ascertain the means
to achieve that result part of the
commander's thinking should also include
assuming the role of the enemy
considering what the enemy's best course
of action may be and deciding how to
defeat it thinking through these
elements helps the commander develop
increased situational awareness so yes
study the situation study how it got
delayed study how it might further
develop it's interesting when we work
with companies because you you get where
the first thing you get is kind of where
they're at like here's where we're at
right now and then you start getting
filled in on on how it got the hell out
there and those are some interesting
stories often and then we're looking at
well how it could develop because one
thing we know is if we develop leaders
and we start to get on the path it's
gonna develop in a great way and if we
don't do that it's gonna be problematic
yeah based on this understanding the
situation the commander can begin to
form a mental image of how the battle
might be fought central to the
commander's thinking must be the
question in this situation what efforts
will be decisive
the commander asks this one this
question not just once but repeatedly as
the battle progresses the commander must
also address the possible outcomes in
the new situations that will result from
those possibilities as the situation
changes so will the solutions and the
actions that derive from it you always
have to reassess what's going on for
every situation the leader must be able
to decide which of the countless and
often confusing pieces of information
are important and reliable the leader
must determine what the enemy is trying
to do and how to counter his efforts the
leaders skill is essentially one of
pattern recognition the ability after
seeing only a few pieces the puzzle to
fill in the rest of the picture
correctly pattern recognition is the
ability to understand the true
significance and dynamics of a situation
with limited information
recognition is a key skill for success
on the battlefield get those overlays
out tack tactics requires leaders to
make decisions and leader must make
decisions in a constantly changing
environment of friction uncertainty in
danger making effective decisions and
acting on those decisions faster than
the enemy is a crucial element of Marine
Corps tactics making decisions faster
sometimes there are sometimes there may
be time to analyze situations
deliberately and consider multiple
options comparing several options and
selecting the best one is known as
analytical decision making when time
allows a commander to apply analytical
decision-making usually before an
engagement or before battle begins that
commander should make the most of it
absolutely once engaged however the
commander finds time is short and they
need and the need for speed is paramount
in some cases speeding up the analytical
decision process may be sufficient
however in most cases intuitive
decision-making is needed to generate
and maintain tempo intuitive
decision-making relies on a commander's
intuitive ability to recognize the key
elements of a particular problem and
arrive at the proper decision without
having to compare multiple options
intuition is not some mysterious reality
not some mysterious quality rather it is
a developed skill grounded firmly in
experience and one that can be further
developed through education and practice
is not without some risk however and
leaders should use the decision-making
style that works for them learn to
detach learn to take a step back make
the intuitive decision-making Krenim
incremental decisions you know Brian
Stann when Brian sand was on here I'll
have to go listen to it again but one
thing I noticed is key always he was
really into the tempo and I I paid
attention that he said you know I wanted
to keep the tempo and you youie
you know certain people they sort of
they sort of grasp on to a tenant and
and it makes really good sense to them
and when Stan was on
like I could see oh yeah he the way he
talked about maintaining that tempo you
know he had a good instructor at that
block of the basic school that really
explained it well and he said okay I get
this I can man I can differ I can go if
I can keep that speed if I can keep that
operational tempo up I can overcome my
enemy I love how they describe the idea
of being intuitive is not magic or
mystery yeah and people write that off a
cow he's got people that are naturally
intuitive actually aren't naturally
intuitive they've cultivated and
developed that through a ton of
experience and the discipline to put
themselves in those situations over and
over and over again and for those of us
on the outside it looks like it's just
natural yeah but it's really a byproduct
of all the times that they've done that
so it is it is natural to them only
because of what they've done to put
those up in that position yeah and
there's like pragmatic things that you
can do to make yourself seem super
intuitive and I do them all the time
there for instance and I was just
writing about this I'll sit there and
there'll be a group of my subordinates
talking about whatever thing we got to
decide on and I'm not saying a damn word
and I'll listen and I'll get all this
great information from all of them about
all the different possibilities of
things way things go and the way things
the outcomes we could have and the
resistance we could meet in these
various areas and I get done listening
to all that for 28 minutes then I
haven't said anything but guess what
I've done is I've taken all those things
and by being detached and by listening
and and by not having a preformed
opinion and by letting my ego not drive
my decision-making when I finally say
hey here's the best way to go forward it
seems like all that the wolf loved he
made that decision really easily
no actually it's it's because I just
listened there's pragmatic things you
can do that yeah make you seem more
intuitive an incremental decision is one
of those things as well because you can
make an incremental decision very easily
because there's less risk in it so when
you say hey listen we just landed and
with the the Germans we haven't had
mitten it met new resistance we're going
forward we're going to go forward three
more miles that seems like a really bow
intuitive decision but really you
haven't met any resistance and it's
pretty easy to make because you're not
over committing so so you seem like this
super cool you're not saying hey we're
going all the way to Rome
you're just saying hey we're just gonna
go three more miles we made it three
we're gonna double it
let's go an different things damn that's
bold yeah but the reality is you haven't
met any with Stern resistance cool let's
rock and roll
am i super intuitive no I'm just
detached I'm assessing and making a
decision well you know I finalist I've
kind of laughing I'm hearing you you
read it and I kind of chuckle to myself
a little bit there's the reason these
seemingly totally simple and obvious
statements need to be said like you need
to assess the situation and figure out
how we got here that it's so easy to
listen to that but in reality it's
really hard for people to do that and
the people that do that the worst are
the ones that are most emotional about
what's going on for the most inside we
we talk about a Tesla in front when we
talk with companies we talk about
detached when we're talking about
prioritized and executing and if I say
prioritize and execute the first thing
that people jump to is I'm gonna get the
right resources and make sure I know
what the right priorities are that is
true but actually individually what you
need to do is you need to detach from
what's going on and make sure that what
seems to be a priority for you isn't a
priority because you're so inside that
it's so emotional about that that you
can't see that actually this thing
changed step beet took us to this and
things are different now and we have to
shift our priorities and it isn't just
people outta resources allocated the
right things those Truitt's are you
detaching the situation so you're
actually doing that correctly so you
don't stay in one place too long or push
too far forward or anything in between
and sounds ready to say you need to
detach and pay attention look and what's
going on around you and we kind of laugh
that it's so hard for some people to do
especially when it's your thing that
you're living on the inside and and when
you do that as a command or do that as a
leader in an organization you can crush
organizations by being so committed to
the thing you're doing in one direction
or another because you're simply just
not detached and when you can show
people with detach
looks like and just pull them out a
little bit and you look around I was at
an F T X two weeks ago mmm so we do this
F T exes and they can be very chaotic
very dynamic there's things going on and
more often than not when you're leading
your team in this FTX is field training
you're getting slaughtered by the enemy
there's 15 of you there's three of them
and they're destroying you because
they'd see what's going on and the
leaders run around and they try to make
decisions and I grab someone who was who
was dead so we put some heat set them
down pull them up and I sat him next to
me and I took about 20 steps away from
the action I said what do you see
just tell me what you see and they say
oh I see a group over here running I see
someone getting cover I see two enemy
running behind that building and they
went on and said about 15 different
things that they say they saw and I said
you know what you see actually you see
everything you're just standing here
looking around cuz you're totally
detached in him and what what do you
think we should do said oh those people
need to get up from behind that building
and run over here like that's what a
good leader does and when they can see
that from the outside in and said of the
inside that all this stuff becomes
obvious and we're listening in a leading
reading sort of laughing about it but
it's actually really hard to do when
you're inside that yeah yeah that's the
that's the classic Seth Stone story I
tell when he had his neck brace on
during land warfare and he wasn't
allowed to participate he said they're
watching his is to ask me to get
annihilated and he says you know can I
help him and I said well hold on a
minute and then they're gonna annihilate
any more nurses can I help him and I
said all right go ahead now and he gives
him you know one quick immediate action
drill and they executed and they're gone
and he says to me man it's so easy when
you're way up here and we would have
literally six inches above the task do
that but when you're and then I told
them you know when we were going through
this training it was like this for me
every time I could see everything
because I was detached that wasn't in
the weeds and that gives you it gives
you this incredible power and visibility
and it happens does it we're not only
here's the thing we're not only talking
about of the battlefield or the
trainings in area we're talking about
any situation we're talking about
business and yes we're talking about
life as well take a step back I had a
friend that was
falling off the cliff with addiction
alcohol alcohol addiction and he was
briefing me on another person that we
knew that was falling off the cliff of
drug addiction and he's sitting there
explaining this to me like I can't
believe yoki kids he doesn't even see
what's happening and so bad and he he
doesn't get it he can't see how bad it
is for himself and I'm sitting there and
I was I was going to the extreme I was
good I know I can't believe how hard I
can't believe he can't see that and I
was describing him because we can't
detach or get caught in relationships
and jobs and scenarios that are bad
because we can't detach and we get
emotional so don't let it happen
leaders with strong situational
awareness and broad experience can act
quickly because they have intuitive
understanding of the situation know what
needs to be done and know what can be
done this insight has often been called
kudu II which is a French term and we've
talked about analyst podcast which
literally means a stroke the eye which
means you take a quick glance at
something and you can understand it it's
also been called tactical sense Union or
mere Adid General John Buford's approach
to the Battle of Gettysburg offers a
good example of understanding the battle
so that it leads to a decision
arriving at Gettysburg with a division
of cavalry in the morning of June 30th
1863 Buford saw Confederate forces
approaching from the northwest with the
bulk of the Union forces still some
miles away Buford was able to
conceptualize the coming battle in his
mind from his position on a hill outside
of town he's de facto detached he could
see that early seizure of the high
ground west of Gettysburg was critical
to giving the Army of the Potomac time
to mass its forces on occupation of this
high ground would also preserve tactical
advantage of the high ground to Buford's
rear for the Union Army once they
arrived on the battlefield Buford also
knew that if the Confederates were
allowed to amass forces first around the
high ground to the south and west Lee
would have the advantage over the
arriving Union forces quickly spreading
out one brigade west
to town along McPherson's Ridge general
buford settled in to defend gettysburg
until the arrival of Union
reinforcements on July 1st the following
day he held his ground against a
division of Confederate infantry
supported by artillery until General
John Reynolds 2nd Corps came up and
reinforced the line general Buford said
ability to foresee the coming battle
take quick action in the disposition of
his forces and hold the high ground
until reinforced was one of the gift
decisive actions that defeated the Army
of Northern Virginia at the Battle of
Gettysburg
Buford's actions at Gettysburg
demonstrated an exceptional ability to
grasp the essence of a tactical
situation through the skills of pattern
recognition recognition and intuitive
decision-making I'm gonna say that when
you get up on the high ground and you
look around you can see things that
other people aren't gonna see and you
can make really good decisions now this
is a physical example but you can
mentally do this as well and you have to
you have to mentally step back detach
acting decisively our ability to
understand the situation is used as if
we're not prepared to act decisively
when the opportunity arrives we must
exploit it fully and aggressively
committing every ounce of combat power
we can muster and pushing ourselves to
the limits of exhaustion the keys to
this effort are identifying enemy
critical vulnerabilities shaping the
operation area to our advantage
designating a main effort to focus our
combat power and acting in a bold and
ruthless manner critical vulnerabilities
for battlefield success is not enough to
generate superior combat power we must
focus that combat power hmm interesting
we must concentrate our efforts on a
critical critical vulnerability that is
a former ability which permits us to
destroy some capability without which
the enemy cannot function effectively
seeking the enemies of vulnerabilities
means striking with our strengths
against his weakness rather than his
strengths and at a time when the enemy
is not prepared this is where we can
often cause the greatest damage at the
lowest cost to ourselves in practical
terms this means avoiding his front the
frontal assault where his attention is
focused and striking his flanks and rear
we did not does not expect us so yes the
front looks all it does exist and it can
be used not the best option very often
not the best option just because a
target is a vulnerable does not however
mean that it's worth attacking we must
direct our resources and strike those
capabilities that are critical to the
enemy's ability to function to defend
attack or sustain himself or to command
his forces we must focus our efforts on
those critical vulnerabilities that will
bend the enemy most to our will most
quickly you know what that makes me
think of when that makes me think when I
see leaders get focused on things that
don't matter that they're gonna get
critical about so you know Dave you're
doing 10 things six three of them are
really important for our organization
there's two of them that are at the
bottom end that aren't really like a big
impact at all you're doing your top
three pretty well you're letting one of
your bottom two just like doing it
horribly I might mention a little
something about it just to make sure it
doesn't go completely off the rails but
I've seen I see leaders that they take
all that focus in it focus on something
that doesn't matter they want to get mad
about you you should have done this or
you should know that and I'm thinking
whoa are you really gonna expend your
leadership capital on that thing that
barely even matters you know going back
to the patches with me in life you know
hey I'm not gonna expend a bunch of
leadership capital on the fact that you
are wearing these patches you know what
I don't like it but cool let's let's
move on what I want you to do life and
Seth I want you guys to plan and execute
awesome missions I want you to take the
fight to the enemy that that's the top
things I want you to do do I want you to
dress professionally yes I do
but that's pretty low on the totem pole
and given where we are in this situation
right now
yeah and leaders will create this this
scenario by which okay if i if i
acquiesce on that one little thing
that's a weakness and they're gonna see
that i don't hold the line on that and
so it's gonna infect everything else and
so they they'll they'll overdo that one
thing because they're I hold though
that's how I lead I hold the line on
everything when in reality the exact
opposite will happen is is they'll
recognize that Iago is actually human
being hey and I'm not gonna just
completely gaff off Jacko and ignore
what
says he's kind of leads give me a little
indication hey don't let this thing fall
so off the rails that it then starts to
affect everything else but what actually
is important is what we're focusing on
and the inflexibility we see leaders
like well I'm gonna hold the line on
everything well guess what not
everything is the same importance and
not everything will have the same impact
on the outcome and what you need to
focus on the most is the things that are
most impactful things that are most
important just patches patches on good
job life at that at the lower tactical
level this may mean using fire maneuver
to take out machine gun position that is
back bone event that is the backbone of
enemy defenses it may mean using a gap
in the enemy's field of fire that allows
us to get into his rear to get to the
rear of his position it may mean
exploiting the enemy's lack of air
defenses by calling in close air support
they may mean taking advantage of an
enemy's lack of mobility by rapidly over
running a key position fashion he can
respond it made me an interdicting enemy
resupply routes when his supplies are
running short
it may mean exploiting a lack of
long-range weapon tree by employing
standoff tactics when whatever we
determine the enemy's critical
vulnerability to be we must be prepared
to rapidly take advantage of it in the
business world so that's that's
something you should always be paying
attention to because we got our business
and that's cool we're gonna do our thing
but what we're what weaknesses do it
does our competitor have and are we
ready to exploit those weaknesses there
is no formula for determining critical
vulnerabilities each situation is
different critical vulnerabilities will
rarely be obvious this is one of the
things that make mastery of tactics so
difficult and one reason that's so few
actions achieve a decisive outcome
identifying critical vulnerabilities is
an important prerequisite to achieving a
decision shaping the operating area once
we have developed an understanding of
the situation and have determined enemy
critical vulnerabilities to attack we
try to shape the operating area to our
advantage
shaping includes both
for non-lethal activities such as
planning fires to fix the enemy using
axis of advance to facilitate movement
designating objectives to focus our
combat power or using deceptive measures
to reinforce enemy expectations I like
that
using deceptive measures to reinforce
enemy expectations because they already
have that idea we're just gonna
reinforce them shaping activities can
make the enemy vulnerable to attack and
Peter divert his attempts to maneuver
facilitate the maneuver of friendly
forces and otherwise dictate the time
and place for decisive battle shaping
forces the enemy to adopt courses of
action favorable to us we attempt to
shape events in a way that allows us
several options so that by the time for
the moment so that by the time the
moment for decisive action arrives we
have not restricted ourselves to only
one course of action through shaping we
gain the initiative perserve momentum
and control the tempo combat so yeah we
have multiple things that we're gonna do
and we'll pick that course of action
when it develops yeah we haven't
determined ahead of time which one we're
gonna use is it gonna be air power
tiller we haven't actually made that
decision yet but we're gonna do things
that will reveal their vulnerability and
then I'm gonna apply whatever that is to
crush them now some people might be
wondering in a day to day or in a
business environment or in life what is
it what were you talking about shaping
operations and this is a very clear
translation of what this means how you
shape operations in the business world
and and in your life what shaping
operations means is that you're out
building relationships with the other
human beings that you're going to be
working with that's what it means we
build up alliances we build up trust we
build up relationships so that when the
things start to unfold we know who we
can count on we know where we stand and
also recognizing they might be the one
that delivers the most critical Momoko
action they might be the one that at the
right
I'm at the most critical moment do the
thing we need them to do absolutely and
if your plan is wait for that moment to
start building that relationship its it
won't work there that's not how it works
you have to go back in time you have to
build that with with the anticipation
not even knowing which one it's going to
be at that time but that relationship
has to be available that it realize it's
here we need to do this now and they're
on board main effort the main effort is
the central maneuver is a central
maneuver warfare concept concentrating
efforts on achieving objectives that
lead to victory of all the actions going
on within our command we recognize a one
as the most critical to success at that
moment the unit assigned responsibility
for accomplishing this key mission is
designated as the main effort the focal
point upon which converges the combat
power of the force the main effort
receives priority for support of any
kind it must be so you get a look at
your life and say like what's your main
effort in your life right and you got to
make sacrifices in other areas that
aren't as important in that particular
time and they're gonna talk about this
to your main effort can change yeah they
can make an adapt
hate my main effort right now I'm
focusing on this thing oh that change
you know I was finishing a book I was
finishing a book and guess what that was
my main effort for like you know I
actually it was the main effort when I
was editing so you get edits back from
your from your editor right and they've
got little ideas there's a time frame
that that's doing so I've got you know
whatever 80,000 word book it's when I'm
writing the book it's not the main
effort because it's just part of what
I'm doing it's an hour a day it's a
thousand words a day boom I look up in
three months and I've got 80,000 words
good okay there wasn't the main effort
then all of a sudden I get back my edits
from my editor and now I've got a and
that's due in six days that becomes my
main 100% because I can't out of time
it's gonna take like three four hours a
day to do the to do those edits so it
has to be the main effort so your main
effort can change in your life but what
you do is you sacrifice other things
like during that time period I was kind
of lucky because I hurt my knee
beautifully hurt my knee couldn't train
it feels like cool there's that editing
needs to get done get it so your your
main effort can can change and adapt and
the same thing happens on the
battlefield faced with a decision we ask
ourselves how can I best support the
main effort so the main effort receives
priority for support of any kind it must
be clear to all of the units in the
command that they must support that unit
in the accomplishment of the mission the
main effort becomes a harmonizing force
for a subordinates initiative faced with
the decision we ask ourselves how can I
best support the main effort and if you
want to be good if you want to create a
good reputation for yourself as a as a
leader and as a human being when you're
not the main effort instead of
complaining and worried that you don't
have the spotlight what you know is you
look at the person that's the sporting
effort you say how can I help you win
yeah
a good leader says when they recognize
that someone else does the main effort
is what can I do to help and all the
time we see it where when you're not the
main effort you know what the bad
leaders do they complain that they're
not the main effort Nora and they argue
and they fight and they stamp their foot
to say I should be the main effort and
even worse they undermine the mayor sure
because they want to see the main effort
fail Dave shouldn't had this I'm gonna
undermine Dave watch him fail yeah and
I'll get the leg up yeah how does that
help you in the long run
oh wait it does no that's right because
you're playing the short game some
actions may support the main effort
indirectly for example commander may use
other forces to deceive the enemy as to
the location of the main effort Marine
Forces used this concept extensively in
conducting a series of combined arms
raised prior to the ground offensive in
Operation Desert Storm the raids were to
confuse the Iraqis as to the true
position and intention of Allied forces
the raid force appeared in the middle of
the night and fired from positions the
enemy had every right to believe or
unoccupied use of a main effort implies
the use of economy of force this term
does not mean that we use as little
force as we think we can get away with
rather it means that we must not fail to
make effective use of all the assets
available to US forces not in a position
to directly support the main effort
should be used to indirectly
supported such forces might be used to
distract the enemy or tie down enemy
forces that might otherwise reinforce
the threatened point uncommitted forces
can be used in this effort by
maneuvering them and faints and
demonstrations that keep the enemy
off-balance and this is something that I
think you mentioned earlier is like oh
yeah like the the person that's not the
main effort has a huge impact on what's
happening so just because you're not the
main effort doesn't mean you shouldn't
do everything in your power to support
the main effort while the commander
always designates a main effort it may
shift during the course of battle as
events unfold because events and the
enemy are unpredictable few battles flow
exactly as the commander is planned
isn't that funny a few battles flow
exactly as the commanders planned as a
result the commander must make
adjustments
how often do I see a commander a leader
have their plan in their head and that's
what they're sticking to yeah we see it
all the time
I'm sticking to the plan and yet few
battles flow exactly as the commander
but it's okay it's by definition spacing
you should not stick with your plan yes
because it's gonna change yes one way is
by redesignating the main effort for
example if company as designated as the
main effort but runs into heavy enemy
resistance while adjacent Company B
makes a breakthrough that as it exploits
a critical vulnerability the battalion
commander may designate Company B as the
main effort this new designation of
Company B as a main effort must not
however be merely nominal it means that
the combat power which was supporting
Company A now shifts to Company B
identifying the main effort is the
principal and most important answered
the question how do we achieve a
decision bold boldness and ruthlessness
you wonder how you achieve a decision
here's how you do it forcing a
successful decision requires the
commander to be bold and ruthless
boldness refers to daring and
aggressiveness in behavior it is one of
the basic requirements for achieving
clear-cut outcomes in order to try for
victory must dare to try for victory we
must have a desire to win
even if we realize that in many
situations that conditions for victory
may not yet be present ruthlessness
refers to pursuing the established goal
mercilessly and single-mindedly
this doubly important this is doubly
important once we gain an advantage once
we have an advantage we should exploit
it to the fullest
we should not ease up but instead
increase the pressure victory in combat
is really a product of the of the
initial plan but rather of ruthlessly
exploiting any advantage no matter how
small until it succeeds and that's where
a lot of people want to stop listening
just that that because that sounds so
fired up that they think cool bold and
ruthless that's out of it all from now
on and then we get into the economy bold
and ruthless boldness and ruthless
ruthlessness must be accompanied by
strong leadership and tempered by sound
judgment without these qualities
boldness can become recklessness and
ruthlessness can be distorted into
cruelty so yes there is a dichotomy in
every aspect of leadership and if you go
too far in one direction or the other
you will fall apart and fail can you
have can you have too much sound
judgment oh yes you can you can sit
there and wait to make the perfect
judgment that that's that's what's got
to be balanced so be careful conclusion
as marine leaders whether of fire teams
or of a Marine Expeditionary Force we
are responsible for achieving success as
you pointed out earlier what are you
gonna get graded on how if you're
successful that's how we're grading you
we don't care how you did it in combat
the success we seek is victory not
merely a partial or marginal outcome
that first all's the final reckoning but
a victory that settles the issue in our
favor to be victorious we must work
ceaselessly in peace
to develop in ourselves a talent from
military judgment the ability to
understand a situation and act
decisively military judgment results
from the wisdom gained from experience
it allows us to identify patterns of
activity and to concentrate our efforts
against a critical vulnerability that
will bend the enemy to our will we must
sharpen our ability to make decisions
intuitively based on our understanding
of the situation boom
so we just did two chapters I thought
we're going to get through three but we
didn't so okay we'll hit the other what
is there eight nine no there's eight
chapters there's eight chapters in this
book we got through two we'll do the
next two on the next one all kinds of
things that sort of lessons learned
inside this and you know we covered that
part that was about stacking the deck in
your favorites killed commander seeks a
victory from the situation that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to stack
the deck in our favor trying to be ready
trying to be prepared not just for
combat obviously but for life for
business through family any
recommendations from you Dave I do have
some recommendations on being prepared
and yeah combat for sure business for
sure and in life for sure
origin USA origin Maine open so
Arlington
so you started jiu-jitsu how long ago
just over a year ago it really it's only
been a year yeah what probably a year in
four months I guess okay so just not
maybe about two months before the origin
camp last year got it which is coming up
next month how often do you overlay what
you see in jiu-jitsu over everything
else that you're doing in your life all
the time now I'm I'm always a little
cautious about talking about it because
uh you're inexperienced I'm
inexperienced but if you're asking me
how often I think about it
and how often I make the connection to
it it's and I say all the time I mean it
all the time and now there's another
layer to that so I got my kids started
on jiu-jitsu about probably bout six
months ago when we had a little we moved
cross-country there's a little gap in
there but I got him set up pretty
quickly here and last week they actually
did a four-week long Jiu Jitsu camp sure
where I'm actually making my money now
is how much better I am at helping my
kids starting to figure things out
they're doing the jujitsu and I'm
actually sort of make connections for
them about their lives and look they
don't see it all they don't but the
impact of that on my life goes well
beyond my personal life right now it's
it's my kids and how impactful that is
and added a long list of regret in my
life if I had started when I when I was
six years old like my son or how
different my life would be but it is it
is awesome man it's awesome yeah it's
it's good to be able to discuss things
and be able to explain things you have
this incredible metaphor for everything
yes if you get that jujitsu on I can't
give my kids combat metaphors but I can
give them jiu-jitsu metaphors that they
actually understand and I'm amazed at
how much more they understand than I
thought because
young they understand that they
understand things and you know the other
thing is you can explain things to them
that they might understand they don't
they don't understand it they understand
it subconsciously and when you make it
conscious for them and they go oh oh I
see oh so I shouldn't just try and stay
in this position I should let that
person move a little bit and look for an
opening oh okay
kind of like when mom's telling me to do
something I shouldn't just get just
trying to hold position I should
actually maneuver a little bit okay I
get it I get it oh I should I should try
and get in a good position hmm yeah if
you start you jitsu which you absolutely
should go to origin main you're gonna
need a key go to origin main get a key
for jiu-jitsu get a rash guard for
jiu-jitsu get workout clothes t-shirts
get some jeans we have origin jeans now
and they're super they're just super
comfortable and super kick-ass so get
yourself some of that we have
supplements joint warfare I just got an
email yesterday from some somebody that
said my mom wanted me to send you an
email to say thank you because she's 71
years old and she's feeling awesome and
I was like cool grandma's ill again
yeah so drone warfare krill oil
discipline discipline go I saw you take
some discipline go yeah prior to us
starting this podcast discipline go
I might have developed a small addiction
to discipline him discipline go it's
honestly the first supplement that I've
taken where I'm like yeah we'll see that
that it it just works this it works and
it's I you so I travel a lot I don't get
a ton of sleep you know the lifestyle we
live right now we're moving there pretty
aggressively and I have to be in the
game I can't I I can't show up me like
hey I'd love to give you my best today
but I'm tired that's not part of the
deal
and you know you can go with the frontal
assault power through method or you can
actually take something's gonna help you
out this stuff is legit man it is legit
and yeah I took it before this cuz you
know what I wanted to be in the game and
how much on the bulk trade is the Burke
family at this point so here's another I
went to your house and I was like oh
this dude's got a problem so here's the
thing man is every time I think I'm on
the train I'm like man I'm so on the
train and I'm like out within the mint
I'm like so on the mint and then the
peanut butter it actually took the
strawberry milk to make me realize what
it really means to be on the dog train
because I you know I keep a little low
profile job you know it echoes I'm not
the key spokesperson for for a mulk bro
when we got strawberry mulkear that is a
whole nother level man and I was you
know I did peanut butter and I kind of
went back to I have not gotten off the
strawberry milk train yet yeah it is
still just it's it's so good and
everybody in the house nobody wants the
other stuff right now and I was you know
I go back to this stuff because that's
it's good I like I'd really like the
other stuff but strawberry right now is
still at the top of the list and it
hasn't moved for a while yeah I finally
got off the strawberry train cuz you
know I cuz I got it before everyone else
yeah and then I was just so deep into it
and plus I was the I was on the warrior
kid strawberry milk that's where it
started so I was already on that so yeah
maybe like a week ago I was having a
little little lunchtime hater and I and
I had some peanut butter and happy so
anyways hey if you want to get some
extra protein in your life check out the
Moke any of those flavors are really
delicious there we go warrior kid milk -
which is awesome for your kids it's
actually crazy that no one made it it's
actually crazy and no one made warrior
kid milk before we did because here oh
you want your kids to drink poison that
sounds like a good plan yeah no one's
feeding their kid poison except for
everyone that's feeding their kid
chocolate milk filled with sugar no one
thought of it cool I did well we'll just
go as warrior kiddin
it's taste awesome your kids are gonna
love it and you got chocolate white tea
too
you can eat the dr.p teabags or you can
get in a can and you can crack that open
and by the way right now we're drinking
actually at this time the or I'm
drinking the the Jocko discipline go in
a can and it's so here's the thing same
thing if you are a parent and you know
that mulk exists you should not buy
anything else because it's not good for
your kids it's not I got the early
sample of the go and it can got to try
that a couple about a month ago
yeah if you when this happens and you
drink it there is no reason to ever buy
a carbonated beverage of any other type
again yeah ever you should not don't the
7up you should never buy 7up ever again
no you won't you won't by 7up you won't
buy redbull you won't buy a coke you
know you'll just buy this because it's
actually good for you and it tastes
awesome blah blah blah alright cool so
that's that and also we do have a store
that's called chocolate or the
is jaw closed or calm and then we got
rash guards and t-shirts and hats and in
hoodies you got some women's gear too by
the way my wife every article of
clothing she now owns has the origin
logo on like everyone and now that we're
out in the West Coast the winter gear
winter gear here is a hoodie yeah that's
a sure and the women's hoodies are
little a lightweight hoodie or we are
still just regular hoodies no
lightweight hoodies yet when he is still
a little she doesn't do lightweight it
says she's cold she puts on the hoodie
I'm a lightweight guy now I got I got
both hoodies I transition to like the
medium way or the lightweight one yep
would you were all echo to put you on
the spot yeah bro how do you like that
right in front of him he did yes he
wants to heath miss eval he was looking
for some validation yeah he did echo
Charles so yeah you can get all that
stuff you can support the podcast at
Ball jockle store comm represent what
does that go say represent while being
on the path that's what he says he says
it in like a sort of a really super
dramatic way if you want to represent
sometimes echo takes long pauses like I
do but there's no sense of
he'll just say if you want to represent
wall you're on the back but eh that's my
brother Michael Charles amen hey we have
this podcast subscribe to it
it's wherever you subscribe to podcasts
leave reviews warrior kid podcast Dave
dude three more just came out a couple
weeks ago burned through my kids were so
fired up because I had episode 14 on
repeat in the car because they will
listen literally listen to those Oread
podcast over and over again even if
they've heard them and we just got
through three new ones in the last week
and they were fired up the stories from
Uncle Jake so good we took the one we
just did it just take just today was um
the kid had the car and the two other
kids wanted that radio control car but
it was expensive and they there's two
paths down to getting that car one which
was a little discipline with your money
save your money safe a little bit here a
little bit there and at the end you know
what you get you get the thing that you
want and there's other kid and you use
an example of ice cream on Fridays at
school for a dollar that literally is
exactly what my kids get from realizing
said yes and they saw that little
delayed gratification yeah kids kids
kids understand it man I know they're
young but they are these stories they
make sense to them they internalize it
they understand it they're not too young
to figure out these life lessons the
classic parables of life that every kid
you just wish and and I think they get
so ingrained with the kids when they
hear these stories they're so relatable
and they go oh yeah it's it's like it's
like embedded in them now they
understand well that it that you have to
delay gratification sometimes for
example they truly understand that you
have to make the right decisions they
truly understand that the world doesn't
center around them they truly understand
that you have to work like it embeds in
their brains so check out that warrior
kid or your kid podcast if you want to
help out a warrior kid you can go to
Irish Oaks ranch calm and Aiden who's a
warrior kid he's just working hard
running a business at the age of
13 he's making soap with goat milk you
can get that soap so you can stay clean
YouTube channel where echo makes legit
videos in his opinion other people have
that opinion as well I do oh you do oh
yeah oh you're an echo Charles those
videos are legit supporter big-time do
you think echo goes overboard from time
to time yes I do
I absolutely get out of balance every
now and then how many explosions can
there be you know Jocko talk yeah where
you say okay that was a bit much yeah 9
is over the limit so there's that
there's yeah yeah if you subscribe to
the YouTube channel then you'll see them
pop up and you're gonna watch it and you
could there's some of them are smaller
so you'd have to listen to a three-hour
podcast which not everyone has done
understood psychological warfare it's
got little short excerpts not even
excerpts there are little short
statements from me if you have a
weakness that you're trying to overcome
you can go to iTunes Google Play mp3 you
can get those and press play when you're
about to take a like take a hit go down
the wrong path yeah
take a step off the path yeah press play
stay on the path that's a good one if
you want a visual representation you go
to flip side canvas calm my brother
Dakota Meyer he's running this business
he's making art for your wall high
quality that say all kinds of good stuff
on him things like good things like this
political freedom so check it out
flipside canvas calm you got on it who's
making all kinds of good stuff check out
their go-to on it calm slash Jocko and
check out some of their various
equipment if you want plain equipment
you can get it there if you are more
like EKKO Charles and you want to have
little artistic things and you can get
that as well
got some books yeah yeah another thing
that's on repeat in my house
are the warded kid books so you
everybody knows there's there's three of
them out there way of the warrior kita
and marks omission or your kid three is
out there where there's a will that book
has been read repeatedly I get to the
end we go back to the beginning every
now and there would be a detour back to
one of the other books one or two but
right now three is on repeat into the
three kids
those books are are legit and even Mikey
and the Dragons even that book even
though it's for younger kids another
book that my kids love not just because
they can read it themselves but because
they actually understand the message of
the story it's so legit those books
those books are awesome and those books
are our must not just for the kids but
for the parents reading a man we got the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
if you want to check that out it's one
of its it's a book that people take
pictures of the book like they take
pictures of the book yeah and I'll tell
you let me tell you a little something
about this book I'll tell you you know
if you've heard me talk smack about my
publisher before your current publisher
my current publisher yeah yeah so yeah
yeah yeah so occasionally I do that
here's one example of me doing that so
inside when you open it up they give the
they give the credit to the design cover
design and they get like somebody that
works there and I'm sure they did they
hooked it up but like I said of this
picture and said okay this is what it's
gotta look like so it's but it they did
do a great job with it and it came out
solid it has black pages they have to
dye the edges black it's a black book
it's called discipline across freedom
field manual the the publisher told me
was the biggest risk he ever took with
publishing a book really yeah he said he
said I I said is this the riskiest book
you've ever cover he was oh my god not
even close
nothing's even close because there's no
pre-existing book anything like that so
you're doing something completely
outside the uncharted territory I hope
it worked out for him it worked out well
for him they worked out well that has
actually worked out awesome and I
appreciate everyone checking that out
it's a book that you know what
you don't you see the big spike in sales
is a graduation time people get it for
elegant ones graduating school oh here
you go here's here's what you should do
now that you're done with high school
get on the path so that's the freedom
disciplines freedom field manual the
audio version of that is not on audible
it's on mp3 so iTunes Amazon music
Google Play whatever and then extreme
ownership do the beginning man a lot of
folks have read it I know
so here's the thing about extreme
ownership has to be read also good for
younger kid I actually read part of that
stuff to my kids they get it but it's
not it's not everything that and
dichotomy together are that they go
together you have to read them both
they're critical and they it explains
how actually even with the lessons in
that first one you can go too far on any
of those principles you can go too far
and you got to bring the economy into
that understanding of extreme ownership
Lafe was telling me maybe like a year
ago he goes you know I was just
rereading extreme ownership because I've
been like trying to figure these he's
like I was trying to figure out a way to
say something and then I read it and I
was like that's it's in there like the
actual answers in there he's like us
trying to recreate a way or craft a way
to say something he's like man I forgot
that I even wrote this section or
whatever so yeah check that out
and what about national on front
national on front the good deal Dave
story continues because I am I'm part of
that team now the lessons all those
things we just talked about not just on
this podcast but in those books Jocko
and llave actually put together this
company that I'm a part of that takes
all those leadership principles and we
help companies solve problems every
problem is solved through leadership
everyone and I'm part of a team that is
not just caring just a good message but
a message that can actually impact
everybody's life business personal every
aspect of it obviously you and life
putting this together came on board with
JP Flint Cochrane Mike Cirelli Mike
bimah Jason Gardner the team has grown
man I'm so stoked to be on this team
with those guys man it does it is legit
how about a gif online
if online is turned out to be even more
important of a resource than I thought
because one of the hardest things we
have to check where the hardest
challenges we have is when we leave a
company is we want to stay as connected
to them as we can and look you're not
that every day oh you mean it's not like
a Rocky movie and we just get pumped up
so that amazingly sometimes thanks more
training than just just just a Rocky
movie yeah what it takes is reps
hundreds and thousands of reps and what
EF online lets people do is get reps rep
after rep after rep and that resource
has proven I knew is gonna be important
I didn't realize how important it was
gonna be not just to reach folks that
can't spend time with us but even once
they spend time with us what they need
to do to reinforce the things that we're
talking about EF online is works in both
directions if we're not working with you
know factor it's there and if we are
working with you they are realizing how
important that is to stay connected to
man it's it's legit and then the muster
I like listening can you talk about this
stuff what about the muster muster I
probably said the word legit too many
times but I'm gonna say it again as a as
a Leadership Conference there's nothing
like it you you have said on every
single podcast the muster is going to
sell out and yet there are still people
that towards the end of signing up and
we put so ask if they can go but not
only did the last one sell out we got
Denver coming up in September it's it's
almost sold out there in September and
we're actually looking so we've got
muster in September coming up in in
Denver on September 19th 20th we also
have Sydney mmm December 4th and 5th ask
me how close we are to selling out
Sydney through close we're gonna sell
out Sydney and our first overseas muster
in December 4th and 5th these events do
the these are these are the things that
put it but these are things that make
the things we talk about they make them
real they make them so really you can
take back from those 2 days and have so
much to go do for yourself to make your
life in your company better there is not
a better way to truly understand what it
is that we're teaching than the muster
it is legit from beginning to end and it
is made
huge impact on folks lives I can't say
how many emails I get I get god only
knows what you're getting of what the
mustard meant to their life to their to
what it did for their life they're all
the next one coming up and down in
Denver go while you still can
it's gonna be close and then there's a F
overwatch which is where we're taking
proven leaders from Special Operations
I'm from combat aviation and we are
placing them into civilian companies
that need leadership
these guys are tested they are proven
they've been in charge they've led
people they've been under stress and
pressure and now they're looking for
their next career why not have their
next career be with you taking the
principles that we talk about all the
time and implementing them into your
organization EF overwatch comm if you
want to get involved with that and if
you want to discuss any of these topics
further you can actually find us on the
interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and on
9000 walk in Dave is at David R Burke
BER ke and I am at JA Kowalik Dave any
closing thoughts my closing thoughts is
that I'm so stoked that I'm here right
now
here on the west coast and gonna be a
part of this man thank you check and to
all you folks out there in uniform that
are executing the tactics that we've
been talking about today in order to
keep our country free thank you and to
our police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service and
all first responders you know I I've
heard a statement that when you hear an
ambulance or you hear a fire it's a
reminder to you that you know you're
someone's having a worse day than you
and that's certainly true but let me
take it one step further because I
actually don't think that when I hear
that siren I think about the people that
are responding those firefighters those
paramedics those police and they're
going to put themselves into harm's away
that's what I think about when I hear
those sirens
so for those of you that do those jobs
for a living
thank you for keeping our homeland safe
and to everyone else out there you gotta
remember we're at war and you were at
war and maybe not a war in the classic
sense of the word that you're out there
with a weapon and you're fighting
against a uniform to enemy but make no
mistake life and I know this might sound
harsh but life is war it's a war against
time it's a war against weakness it's a
war against ego it's a war against the
most base part of you as a human being
so as the Marine Corps doctrine says
actively and aggressively seek it out
and when the opportunity arrives level
every ounce of power you can muster
pushing beyond the limits of exhaustion
to achieve total victory and until next
time this is Jocko and Dave out